Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit im
über Raumfahrt und andere kosmische Angelegenheiten. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zur Ausgabe 97 hier bei Raumzeit.
Wo äh ich weiterhin wild auf Reisen bin und heute hat mich der Weg nach Darmstadt geführt.
Manche Leute schon denken, ja Darmstadt kennen wir schon. Nee, weit gefiel. Darmstadt hat ja noch eine ganze Menge mehr zu bieten, aber ich bin nur wenige Meter davon entfernt.
Nicht im europäischen Raumfahrtkontrollzentrum, sondern ein paar Meter weiter beim Eumetsat.
Und was das ist und was ist äh das alles so macht und kann und tut, darüber spreche ich jetzt mit Christian Bank. Hallo, herzlich willkommen bei Raubzeit.
Ja hallo, Tim, grüß dich.
Ja Christian, du bist hier ähm bei ist die Organisation, die die europäischen,
Satelliten betreibt. So kann man das, glaube ich, mal grob umschreiben
eine äh etwas eigenständige äh Organisation, die so neben den ganzen anderen internationalen europäischen äh Organisationen in der Raumfahrt wie der ESO oder der ESA existierte nochmal so seinen ganz eigenen äh Kosmos äh macht.
Bisher genau wofür zuständig.
Bin hier bei der Direktor für die Entwicklung von neuen Satellitensystemen.
Das heißt, äh wir schauen in die Zukunft, was wir in Zukunft an Daten brauchen, definieren dann neue Satelliten und neue Instrumente und die entwickeln wir dann zusammen mit der europäischen Raumfahrtagentur.
Mhm. Super. Bevor wir in die Zukunft gucken, würde ich ganz gerne ein bisschen äh in die Vergangenheit äh schauen. Deine konkrete eigene äh Vergangenheit. Was ähm hat dich denn auf diese Spur in die Sterne äh gebracht?
Schon immer dabei gewesen.
Bin tatsächlich ein äh ein eingefleischter Raumfahrt-Nerd. Bin jetzt aber relativ spät erst zu dem Thema ähm meteorologische Satelliten gekommen,
Mal angefangen äh in der Kindheit mit Astronomie und bin dann sehr schnell,
und den Viking zu Mars gelandet und habe mich sehr dafür interessiert, warte zuerst in den astronomischen Raumfahrten der wissenschaftlichen Raumfahrt. Und ähm das habe ich eine ganze Weile sehr intensiv verfolgt,
und bin dann aber bald nach dem Studium, als ich äh angefangen habe zu arbeiten,
zur bemannten Raumfahrt gekommen. Damals war das Thema Spacelab und Space Shuttle ganz intensiv diskutiert in Deutschland.
Und das hat mich dazu gebracht, ähm in die bemannte Raumfahrt hineinzugehen. Ich habe damals studiert bei Professor Ernst Messerschmidt in Stuttgart.
Und das war ja ein früherer deutscher Astronaut, der damals aufs Spacelab geflogen ist und äh der hat mir sozusagen nochmal einen kleinen Schubs gegeben in die bemannte Raumfahrt. Ich habe dann sehr lange,
mitgearbeitet an der Entwicklung der internationalen Raumstation an Kolumbus an dem Modul. Damals war ich in Bremen und ähm,
Ja und dann von dort aus als das Kolumbusmodul gestartet war und lief an Bord der Raumstation,
bin ich dann über verschiedene Stufen zum Beispiel Raketenweiterentwicklung der Ariane, aber auch äh bemannte Vehikel, ATV et cetera,
dann schließlich hier gelandet und jetzt bin ich hier bei eben für die Entwicklung von meteorologischen Klimasatelliten zuständig.
Ganz gut rumgekommen. Was war das für ein Studium Physik.
Nee, das war tatsächlich Luft- und Raumfahrttechnik.
Raumfahrttechnik an der äh.
Uni Stuttgart in Vaying.
Uni Stuttgart. Alles klar.
Okay, aber dann doch schon äh ziemlich straight forward eigentlich in diesem Bereich äh reingegangen und ein bisschen über Pingpong dann letzten Endes hier äh gelandet.
Ja die Wetterbeobachtung ist ja so ein bisschen so ein so so der Klassiker.
Ähm unter den Raumfahrtenmissionen würde ich sagen, das ging ja schon relativ früh los. Und.
Das Interesse am Wetter war ja auch schon immer groß. Nicht wahr? Also das ist ja so die eigentlich so die klassische Zukunftsvorhersage, ne? Also wenn man über die Zukunft redet, dann redet man irgendwie über das Wetter.
Das ist das ist so das, was alle interessiert. Das ist natürlich auch einen praktischen Nutzen, auch über so den täglichen hinaus, ist es halt einfach auch für
Agrarindustrie sehr äh wichtig. Der Bauer hat's schon immer an den Wolken gesehen, wie es in den nächsten zwei Wochen wird, aber das Gefühl haben auf der einen Seite nicht anderer aller und man wollte ja dann auch äh etwas,
Daten äh bekommen. Diese ganze Wetterbeobachtung ist
ist wahrscheinlich so alt wie die wie die menschliche Zivilisation würde ich sagen, ne. Aber dass die Technik dort
äh Einzug gehalten hat, ist ja eigentlich auch eher ein jüngeres äh Phänomen so. Ähm und es ist ja vor allem auch noch Technik, die ja das, was hier bei Omez hat, äh gemacht wird.
Begleitet ja auch noch eine eine wichtige Rolle spielt, also Messstationen an den verschiedensten Orten, ähm Wetterballons
und jetzt weiß ich gar nicht, ob ich noch irgendwann eine ganz wichtige Basistechnologie an dieser Stelle äh vergessen habe, bevor es in den Orbit geht.
Also wenn wir Wetterstationen sagen, sind das natürlich die Stationen an Land, aber eben auch Bojen,
Wir haben ja 70 Prozent der Erdoberfläche mit Wasser bedeckt. Das heißt, dort haben wir Wetterstationen auf den Meeren. Leider nicht so dicht wie an Land. Und wenn wir äh in die Atmosphäre gucken, dann haben wir neben den Wetterballons zum Teil auch noch Höhenforschungsraketen.
Aber das ist im Grunde genommen schon eine sehr gute Übersicht. Also äh die äh die Messinstrumente äh hier am Boden,
die wir sehr kontinuierlich betreiben können und ablesen können,
ähm die aber daran gebunden sind, dass letztlich ähm ja eine Verbindung irgendwo in Netzwerke besteht, dass wir die automatisieren können. Früher waren das einfach Barometer, Thermometer, jetzt sind das sehr komplexe Messstationen,
und äh diese Systeme, die in die Höhe gehen, also in die Atmosphäre und versuchen Messdaten aus verschiedenen Höhenregionen der Atmosphäre zu gewinnen.
Betreibt denn sowas? Auch?
Nein, da sind wir nicht engagiert. Wir konzentrieren uns tatsächlich auf die nächste Dimension dann, nämlich von oben runter zu gucken,
von oben auf die Atmosphäre zu gucken und entweder äh auch Höhenprofile ähm zu gewinnen in der Atmosphäre oder eben die gesamte,
gesamte Säule der Atmosphäre zu durchleuchten und ein Gesamtmesswert da zu bekommen.
Was sind denn so die die Dinge, die heute gemessen werden? In an all diesen Orten, also Barometer, klar, Luftdruck hatten wir schon, Thermometer, die Temperatur, das sind so die die naheliegenden äh Dinge, äh Wind äh sicherlich äh auch.
Windgeschwindigkeit, Luftfeuchtigkeit und so weiter. Ähm das sind alles äh Parameter der der atmosphärischen Physik, also der klassischen Thermodynamik,
ähm die hier eine ganz große Rolle spielen, ähm wie sich die Atmosphäre lokal ähm aber auch auf auf äh größer räumigen Skalen, also äh Kontinentalweit bis eben zu global entwickelt.
Und ähm ich hätte jetzt ich habe es deshalb gefragt, also ist ja klar. Da steht's äh ja schon im Namen, nicht weil hier geht's einfach äh primär um Satelliten. Ich dachte nur gerade
dass das vielleicht auch das Zusammenspiel mit diesen Bodenstationen zur Kalibration oder so der Satelliten auch jetzt nicht ganz unerheblich äh sein könnte. Ist jetzt
so eine Vermutung.
Ja, absolut. Doch doch, also das muss man äh ganz klar festhalten, dass äh man Satellitendaten nicht isoliert,
irgendwie nehmen kann, sondern dass die Kalibrierung äh mit den,
real gemessenen Daten hier am Boden ganz wichtig ist. Wir haben auch äh wenn wir einen Satelliten in Betrieb nehmen, da kommen wir vielleicht nachher noch drauf,
sehr lange Kampagnen der Kalibrierung, wo wir die Instrumente an Bord des Satelliten abgleichen mit den Messwerten, die wir hier am Boden gewinnen, sodass wir sicher sein können, dass das, was wir über einer Messstation.
Kommen, wo wir wissen, das ist der genaue Wert, dass das eben auch,
Wert ist, wenn wir übers Meer fliegen, wo keine Messstation ist, wo wir also diese Kalibrierung nicht machen können, aber uns drauf verlassen können, dass der vom Satelliten gemessene Wert eben dort auch stimmt. Diese Kalibrierung ist ganz wichtig und ich denke auch, dass für die äh Meteorologen,
Ähm viele, viele Daten in ihre Wettermodelle einfließen und insofern sind Satellitendaten eben nur ein Teil dessen.
Als dann klar war, dass Satelliten äh eine gute Idee sind, weil man wollte ja natürlich von oben schauen und ich kann mich noch selber ganz gut dran erinnern, wie das so.
Damals so losging im Fernsehen, in den siebziger Jahren, da war ich jetzt auch noch recht jung, aber irgendwie
es fing halt irgendwie an, da war dann immer nur so eine Tafel,
mit den Linien und ein paar Pfeilen und das war dann irgendwie so das Wetter. Und ich glaube dann so in den achtziger Jahren ging das dann irgendwie los. Dann hatte man halt immer diese Meteorosatbilder, so stand der auch drauf und das waren so diese
Für heutige Verhältnisse sehr äh verausschten Nebelwände, wo man so gesehen hat, so
Ja okay, gut, sind Wolken über Europa so. Vielmehr konnte man nicht rauslesen, aber das war ja dann schon auch so eine so eine so eine Technik kulturelle Revolution, die dann eben so langsam übers Fernsehen äh zu
allen dann äh ausgespielt wurde. Zu welchem, wie hat sich denn das jetzt sozusagen äh.
Entwickelt, wo fing äh äh das an, dass man gesagt hat, okay, wir müssen jetzt die Raumfahrt auch fürs Wetter benutzen.
Ähm also den den ersten Schritt haben dort tatsächlich die die Amerikaner gemacht, die äh schon in den späten 50ern und Anfang der sechziger Jahre,
Tests gemacht haben, indem sie von Satelliten äh einfach Fotos,
äh Wolken gemacht haben und dann äh versucht haben, die auszuwerten, hat damals natürlich diese Kette,
vom Fotografieren des Satelliten bis hin zur Auswertung durch einen Meterologen relativ lange gedauert. Da war das Wetter dann schon eine Weile vorbei, bis das soweit war. Es konnte man also kaum wirklich zu einer Echtzeitauswertung nutzen.
Es war im Prinzip überhaupt das der der erste Blick überhaupt mal von oben, den man überhaupt erst mal gewonnen hat, weil man saß ja bis dahin immer nur von unten und hatte wahrscheinlich gar keine Vorstellung, schon gar nicht darüber, wo sind denn überall immer gleichzeitig Wolken, kommen die nur manchmal oder.
Absolut und was kann man vor allen Dingen von oben sehen und was kann man nicht sehen? Ähm und dieses Verständnis dafür zu entwickeln, das war glaube ich auch erstmal sehr wichtig, wo sind die Möglichkeiten, aber auch die Grenzen dieser dieser reinen Fotografie.
Und ähm 1967 hatte man dann den ersten Satelliten, der tatsächlich regelmäßig.
Auch farbliche Bilder von oben gemacht hat aus dem geostationären Orbit, November 67 fingt es an und seitdem hat man solche Wolkenfilme.
Ähm aus dem Orbit.
Und als das sich herausstellte, dass das äh ein gutes Mittel ist, um zum Beispiel entstehende Stürme oder Wetterfronten zu erkennen, die großräumig sich entwickeln, hat man dann gesagt, gut, das brauchen wir operationell. Das ist eine gute Ergänzung zu unseren bodengebundenen Vorhersagen.
Und hat dann ähm Anfang der 70er Jahre in den USA die ersten wirklichen dedizierten Wettersatelliten gehabt.
Die Europäer haben sich das angeguckt, haben äh gesagt, das ist tatsächlich sehr, sehr hilfreich. Wir wollen das über Europa auch haben,
amerikanischen Satelliten haben natürlich primär auf die USA und auf Nordamerika geguckt, bisschen auch auf Südamerika, aber Europa war eben nicht,
vollständig abgedeckt, nur der Nordatlantik. Und darum hat Europa gesagt, wir brauchen ein System haben, was Europa komplett abdeck.
Und so fing dann die Entwicklung der Meteorosatz an des ersten Meteosatz.
Wie soll denn das technisch aus? Also der erste Sattel liegt, glaube ich, war dieser Tiros äh Satellit in äh sechziger Jahren.
Ähm oder das war so ein so ein komplettes äh Programm von verschiedenen ähm Satelliten, die ja im Prinzip mit dem Ziel irgendwie mal Großwetterlage äh abzudecken, so entwickelt äh wurden. Was war das so für eine Technik? Womit hat man dann,
überhaupt auf die Erde geschaut, weil so Liveübertragung, das war ja wahrscheinlich alles noch so analoge Funktechnik.
Ja? Ja, aber damals fing das tatsächlich schon an, dass man mit lichtempfindlichen Zellen, mit Fotozellen,
ähm die Erde äh abgescannt hat. Ähm man hat also äh versucht äh tatsächlich äh die die die das Bild der Erde in elektronische Daten gleich in Messwerte zu übersetzen, also.
Schon digitalisiert auch.
Ja, also nicht digitalisiert im heutigen heutigen Sinne, es waren schon analoge,
Messwerte damals, aber die sind per Funk und dann auch in in sehr kurzer Zeit zum Boden gefunkt worden,
um tatsächlich einzufließen in die realen Wettervorhersagen und das muss ja dann schon relativ bald passieren, ne? Sonst sagt man das Wetter von gestern voraus. Das ist nicht immer interessant,
und äh und äh diese Kette aufzubauen, ja? Wie man möglichst schnell die Satellitendaten zum Boden und in die Vorhersage hineinbekommt. Das hat man damals ganz gut gelernt und das waren wirklich Wegbereiter von digitalen Kameras, wie wir sie heute kennen,
von ja elektronischen Kameras einfach, die nicht mehr per Film Fotos machen und erst dann entwickelt werden muss.
Und abgetastet werden muss, äh wie es bei den allerersten Satelliten der Fall war, ähm sondern dass man hier tatsächlich eine sofortige Umsetzung,
Messung in einen elektrischen Messwert hat und den dann zum Boden funken kann. Und äh das war Voraussetzung dafür, äh dass wir dann die digitalen Kameras hatten und die die ähm äh Einbringung der Messwerte direkt in die Wettervorhersage-Modelle, wie wir das heute kennen.
Und mit welchen Orbits äh fing das an? Also so ein so ein Orbit wie es die ISS hat, ist ja für Wetterbeobachtung,
eher nicht so äh geeignet, weil man will ja mehr oder weniger immer den selben Bereich anschauen, aber so geosynchrone Satelliten gab's, glaube ich, zu dem Zeitpunkt auch noch gar nicht, oder.
Doch, das hat man dann auch relativ äh schnell ähm aufgenommen, dass man diese Satelliten äh in den geostationären Orbit gebracht hat. Wie gesagt damals in den in den späten sechziger Jahren,
und äh dann ein zweiter Orbit, der noch dazukam, ähm war dann der Sonnensynchroner, der sogenannte Sonnensynchrone Orbit,
der jeden,
Ort in der Welt zur gleichen lokalen Zeit überfliegt und damit immer mit dem gleichen, mit den gleichen Lichtverhältnissen äh fotografieren kann. Das ist ganz hilfreich, dann muss man sich nämlich dieses Helldunkel-Wechsel zwischen Tag und Nacht nicht mehr rausrechnen, sondern hat dann an jedem Ort,
ähm den gleichen Sonnenstand.
Also ein polarer Orbit Nord-Süd äh über die Pole äh hinweg, aber quasi so in der Geschwindigkeit, dass man mit der Sonne mitzieht.
Genau, genau. Und diese beiden Orbits sind nach wie vor auch heute die wichtigsten Orbits, also der geostationäre, um eine Halbkugel permanent zu anzuschauen. Das haben wir mit Metoset hier für Europa.
Äh und der Sonnensynchrone, der die ganze Welt abdecken kann, wo's aber eben ähm einen halben Tag dauert, bis man die gesamte Welt einmal abgescannt hat.
Wo man auch die ganze Zeit Licht auf den Solarpanelen hat. Ist ja auch noch so ein so ein Nebeneffekt, genau. Das heißt mit fing es an und man hat dann relativ schnell gemerkt so oha okay
bringt auch was. Also die Daten, die man da äh gewinnt,
Was war denn das im Prinzip für Daten, die man gewonnen hat durch diesen reinen Videoblick? Weil es war jetzt quasi nur Licht im sichtbaren Bereich, wie wir das von unseren Augen her äh kennen. Was was lässt sich denn äh daran überhaupt ablesen?
Ähm ja, das waren tatsächlich erstmal reine Fotos. Es gibt also noch die Anekdote, dass die ersten Fotos, die dann von dem Meteorsatz zur Erde gesendet wurden,
hier tatsächlich in Darmstadt ankamen, damals noch bei den Kollegen von der Isog,
auf dem Bildschirm erschienen und dann mit einer Sofortbildkamera, mit einer Polaroid abfotografiert wurden und,
Polaroid Foto wurde dann per Autokurier nach Offenbach gefahren, wo der deutsche Wetterdienst sitzt und dort von dem Meteorologen sozusagen angeschaut und dann interpretiert.
Das waren so die allerersten Dinge und dann ist klar, aus diesen Art von Fotos kann man natürlich nur ganz begrenzte Informationen ziehen. Man kann sehen, wo große Wetterfronten
entlang laufen, ja? Wo sich äh Instabilitäten in der Atmosphäre entwickeln, wo große Sprünge in Temperatur,
Dampfdruck et cetera sich ausbilden.
Oder große Stürme, Hurricanes.
Das sind Dinge, die natürlich erst mal unterstützend wirken, weil eigentlich hätte man die Daten auch aus den Wetterstationen, äh aber man hat das Ganze bildlich noch mal vor sich und ich glaube, damals in den siebziger Jahren war es für die Meteorologen,
Einfach erst mal wichtig, dass nebeneinander zu halten und zu.
Korrelation herzustellen. So sieht es aus und so war's.
Was sagt mir das eine oder sagt mir das andere? Bei den Messwerten habe ich riesen Zahlenkolonnen oder eine Karte mit ganz vielen Messwerten, die eingetragen sind nomerisch. Bei dem Foto habe ich einen,
visuellen Eindruck und als Mensch, als visuelles Tier, kann man aus so einem Bild ja nochmal ein bisschen mehr äh äh herauslesen,
und äh das übereinander zu bringen, das war erstmal ein Lerneffekt. Heutzutage sind wir natürlich einige Schritte weiter. Das heißt, wir haben erstmal,
in den elektronischen Bildern sehr viel stärkere ähm Granularität und sehr viel größere Feinheit der einzelnen Lichtwerte, wenn man so will,
die kann man elektronisch verstärken. Das heißt, wir können jetzt nicht nur nur die großen äh äh Regenwolken sehen
sondern wir können tatsächlich auch Cyruswolken sehen, ganz feine Eiswolken. Wir können Wolken in verschiedenen Höhen sehen und damit auch interpretieren. Was sind das eigentlich für Wolken und was haben die für einen Einfluss auf das lokale Wetter?
Man kann auch sehen, in welcher Höhe sie sind.
Ja, in welcher Höhe sie sind, ob sie aus Wassertröpfchen, aus Eiskristallen bestehen et cetera.
Aber das lässt sich das schon rein visuell äh herauslesen oder.
Man aus den elektronischen Messwerten dann herausrechnen, indem man verschiedene Farben miteinander kombiniert. Das ist dann der nächste Schritt.
Wenn wir ein Mehrfarbenfoto haben, sage ich mal, da also ein ein ein äh Bundfoto sozusagen.
Also gefiltert.
Durch verschiedene Farbfilter. Dann können wir durch die Kombination dieser verschiedenen Farben bestimmte ähm Wolken besser hervorheben oder herausfiltern.
Und dann äh daraus herauslesen, ähm ja, was das für ein Typ Wolken ist, woraus die bestehende Höhe die sind, was bis hin zur Frage, was für eine Temperatur die haben und so weiter und das liefert natürlich nochmal großflächig.
Ganz viele zusätzliche Informationen, die sie aus reinen Bodenmesswerten in der Form so nicht haben.
Anfang äh zurück. Also das waren jetzt so quasi die ersten Erkenntnisse aus äh natürlich jetzt noch nicht in dieser Feinheit, wie wir sie jetzt schon äh angedeutet haben, aber es war so klar
bringt was so. Also Satelliten da oben zu haben, das das erweitert äh im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes den den Blick auf die Angelegenheit und ähm,
nachdem man dann wahrscheinlich auch ein paar Jahre diese Korrelation durchgeführt hat und gesagt hat, okay, so sieht's aus. Das war, was wir da an Luftfeuchtigkeit, Luftdruck et cetera, Wind und so weiter hatten. Man sieht schon so erste äh Patterns und,
noch nicht alles wissen, äh ist absehbar, dass umso besser man draufschaut, umso mehr wird man äh vorhersagen können und das hat ja dann dieses ganze Wettersatellitenprogramm beschleunigt,
angedeutet. Irgendwann waren dann auch die Europäer so weit, die halt mit ihrer Raumfahrt ohnehin,
ein wenig hinterher hingen und in den siebziger Jahren in dem Sinne noch gar keine wirklichen großen Missionen oder auch nur Strukturen äh,
hatten. Wie fing das dann an, dass es so einen europäischen Move gab in diesem Bereich.
Also wir hatten schon in den 60er Jahren in Europa ja zwei Organisationen, die Eldo und die Esro,
Die Ello hat damals den Vorläufer der Ariana versucht zu entwickeln, also eine eigene Trägerrakete.
Ähm und die Esro hat damals die ähm ja die Satelliten, die Anwendungssatelliten, die Forschungssatelliten entwickelt und das ist der die beiden sind die Vorläufer der Esa.
Also European Launcher Development Organisation, dafür steht äh Eldo. Das wurde dann später dann Ariane Spass und die European Space Research Organisation Esro und das war dann Isar. Mhm.
Genau, das das ging dann über in die Isar und äh die ist ja Anfang der 70er Jahre dann sozusagen entstanden aus der Zusammenführung dieser beiden,
und äh da war das Thema äh Anwendung in der Raumfahrt ganz wichtig und da ist auch das äh das eigentliche Meteosat-Programm zuerst entstanden. Also die Esa hat dann einen ersten Prototypen entwickelt,
basierend auf den Informationen und auf den Erfahrungen, die die Amerikaner mit ihren äh Satelliten schon gesammelt hatten,
und hat sich überlegt, wie man das am besten mit europäischer Technologie ähm realisieren kann,
Das waren dann, es war ein geostationärer Satellit, der spinnt stabilisiert war, das heißt, der hat sich wie ein Kreisel um sich selbst gedreht.
Und konnte durch dieses Kreiseln mit einem Objektiv die Erde immer zeilenweise abtasten. Ne, bei jeder Umdrehung hat er eine Zeile abgetastet und konnte da dadurch sehr fein die Messwerte von äh von der Erdoberfläche dann abtasten.
Man brauchte auch nicht so ein großes, breites Sensorfeld, wo man dann unter Umständen noch das Problem hat, dass die,
einzelnen Messelemente alle unterschiedlich funktionieren, unterschiedlich gut funktionieren, dadurch dass man sich durchdreht und das mit einer Zeile abtastet hat man sozusagen auch wirklich zumindest auf einer Zeile auch immer dasselbe Eingabegerät in dem Moment.
Genau, also da hat man diese diese Fehler zum Beispiel nicht äh als Problem gehabt.
Scanner im Prinzip. Genau.
Genau, ne. Der hat ein eine Scanachse war sozusagen der Drehende, der sich drehende Satellite. Es gab dann noch eine zweite Scannerachse, nämlich einen Spiegel, der hat also die Nord-Südrichtung,
immer gekippt, ne. Das heißt, der äh die Zeile Ost-West war durch die Satellitendrehung gegeben und die Nord-Südablastung durch einen Spiegel. Und ähm,
dadurch hat man also alle 30 Minuten sozusagen die äh die Seite der Erde, die man gesehen hat, die halbe Erdkugel komplett abgetastet. Und äh.
Dieser Spin war eher langsam.
Ja, äh ich glaube, der Spinnen war, ich muss mal überlegen, irgendwas in Richtung fünfzehn Umdrehungen pro Minute oder so was in der Richtung oder zehn Umdrehungen pro Minute, irgendwas in der Gegend. Nageln Sie mich auf den Zahlenwert.
Ich wollte jetzt nur wissen, ob das Ding wie irre sich dreht oder äh langsam so um sich herumschält.
Nein, nein. Also das das wiegt ja dann auch durchaus äh so seine zwei Tonnen, also den Kreisel, wenn der sich dann auch der Umdrehung dreht, dann hat er einen ganz guten Drehmoment.
Und damit auch eine gute Stabilisierung.
Ganz genau. Ja und das System war eigentlich recht erfolgreich, sodass man gesagt hat, ähm das war der erste Meteott.
Das war dann schon der.
Was da schon Meter satt, genau und da hat man gesagt, da möchte man gern mehrere davon haben, hat zwei, drei Nachbauten von diesem Satelliten erst mal gemacht, damit man kontinuierlichen Service aufbauen kann, ja, also es bringt ja den,
Wetterdiensten wenig, wenn sie äh mal für zwei Jahre Messwerte haben und dann ist wieder für fünf Jahre kein Messwert. Also das ist äh nicht hilfreich, um,
kontinuierlich die Wettervorhersagen zu verbessern, sondern es war klar, es muss ein kontinuierlicher Service sein.
Darum schnell erstmal zwei Nachbauten von diesen Satelliten, die hat man auch gestartet in Betrieben und dann kam der Punkt, wie können wir das verbessern?
Weiterentwickelte zweite äh Generation dieser Meteorosatz entwickelt. MSG Methous hat second generation.
Und äh die fliegen tatsächlich bis heute. Der letzte Satellit wurde 2015 gestartet aus dieser Familie. Und die liefern heute uns die Wetterkarten, die wir äh im Fernsehen, in den Wetterberichten sehen.
Und äh ja hat sich für Europa wirklich als äh sehr sehr positiv herausgestellt. Mittlerweile.
Nicht nur die Amerikaner und die Europäer derartige Satelliten, sondern auch in Asien, gibt's Japan zum Beispiel, China, die haben auch solche Wettersatelliten, Russland ebenso. Und mittlerweile haben sich diese ganzen,
Organisationen so weit abgesprochen, dass sie die Wetterdaten miteinander austauschen. Wir können also quasi permanent die Erde rundherum mit Wertesatelliten beobachten.
Mhm. Ohne dass irgendeine Stelle jetzt nicht mehr abgedeckt wäre?
Ja genau, aus dem geostationären Orbit haben wir eine komplette Abdeckung der der Erde.
Aussah der Pole oder.
Ja natürlich, das ist natürlich schwierig zu sehen vom geostationären Arbeit, der ist ja überm Äquator und da ist der Polen natürlich ähm ja nur noch.
Aber es gibt ja dann auch noch die Polanobits, die müssten das ja wunderbar mitkriegen.
Ganz genau, dafür haben wir dann die Polarensatelliten. Aber ähm dadurch, dass die der größte Teil der Bevölkerung äh eben in einem Band von, ich sage mal, plus 70 bis minus.
Antarktiswässer ist jetzt vielleicht mal interessant zum Nachschlagen irgendwann, aber so täglich braucht man das jetzt.
Ist ein ist ein Spezialthema, ist hat natürlich große Auswirkungen auch auf unser Wetter. Wie oft hören wir davon, dass Polarstürme nach nach Kanada und in die USA einbrechen und auch die Blizzards verursachen? Auch hier in Europa haben
immer wieder Kaltwettereinbrüche, das kommt von den Polregionen, deswegen ist das Wetter nicht völlig unwichtig,
Müssen wir beobachten, insbesondere jetzt, wo die Eisbedeckung immer weiter abnimmt und dass immer größere Variabilität zeigt, dieses Wetter dort, aber es ist klar, dass äh,
Für uns ist wichtig, der Nordatlantik, was kommt aus Afrika,
auch was kommt ausm Norden und was kommt aus Sibirien? Also wir müssen aus allen Richtungen gucken und deswegen ist es für uns so wichtig, dass wir die Daten weltumspannend haben und mit allen austauschen können.
Das heißt also sowohl die erste als auch die zweite Generation sind geosynchrone äh Satelliten gewesen mit äh eins bis weiß nicht sieben oder so, glaube ich, die ähm also die erste Generation war glaube ich bis sieben.
Waren erst eins bis drei und dann haben wir vier bis elf jetzt.
Okay und es gibt aber auch schon eine dritte Generation.
Ja, das ist dann der Blick in die nahe Zukunft. Ähm die,
Technologie gerade für die Kameras und für diese Scans, wie ich sie eben beschrieben habe, ja durch das Drehen des Satelliten, die hat sich
Wie wir alle wissen, in den letzten Jahrzehnten enorm weiterentwickelt. Wir alle haben jetzt Digitalkameras in den Handys, aber auch vorher hatten wir ja schon die normalen Filmkameras sind ja ersetzt worden durch Digitalkameras und das spiegelt ja nur wider, welche Technologie insgesamt verfügbar ist.
Man hat auch für die Satelliten irgendwann mal gesagt, ähm es hat Vorteile, wenn wir diese geostationalen Satelliten nicht mehr als,
sich drehende, spinnstabilisierte Satelliten machen, sondern tatsächlich als Dreiachsen stabilisierte Satelliten, die also tatsächlich immer mit dem Gesicht sozusagen, mit dem Kameraobjektiv auf die Erde schauen,
und äh das ist zwar anspruchsvoller, was die Lageregelung angeht und auch was die Kameratechnik angeht, aber diese Technologie steht mittlerweile zur Verfügung und dann wiegen die Vorteile, die man aus so einer Konfiguration bekommt.
Den höheren Aufwand aus, den man in die Kameras und in die Regelung stecken muss.
So drei drin die ähm das halt einfach äh ausdrehen sozusagen.
Ja genau. Verschiedene Systeme, die den Satelliten stabil immer auf die Erde ausrichten, sodass also diese jetzt kommende Generation und wir sprechen hier tatsächlich von 202undzwanzig Ende 2022, also in etwa 15 Monaten,
wird dann die dritte Generation der Meteorsatz starten MTG Meteorsat firth Generation. Das wären dann,
drei Achsen stabilisierte Satelliten sein, aber das Prinzip ist wieder das Gleiche, die Erde kontinuierlich mit hoher Auflösung zu fotografieren und dort insbesondere sich zu konzentrieren auf alle Daten und alle Informationen, die für Wetter und Klimarelevant sind.
Wie viele Meter sind denn jetzt grade gleichzeitig im Betrieb.
Wir haben ähm wir können sagen vier Satelliten im Betrieb, davon sind zwei ähm komplementär. Der eine Satellit konzentriert sich auf Europa.
Der zweite Satellit ähm fotografiert quasi die Halbkugel, die man vom geostationären äh Orbit aus sieht.
Dritter Satellit liefert einen Backup-Service.
Und ein vierter Satellit ist über dem indischen Ozean, das heißt dort haben wir die Region, die wir mit unseren Meteorsatz abdecken, bisschen weiter nach Osten noch verschoben und können also bis in den indischen Ozean und auch bis über Sibirien hinaus äh die Wettersysteme beobachten.
Das Backup ist im Backup für welchen für für die also entweder oder, weil der also weil der Fokus sozusagen kann angepasst werden. Worauf man genau schaut.
Ja und wir haben auch durch diese verwendete Kameratechnik an Bord der Satelliten gibt es immer mal wieder Auszeiten, also die Kameras müssen immer mal wieder,
sozusagen nachkalibriert werden, brauchen mal eine Ruhepause, gerade dieser sich kippende Spiegel, den ich vorhin erwähnte, der die Nord-Süd-Ausrichtung macht. Dieser Mechanismus ist äh,
bisschen pflegeintensiv. Ähm und der braucht Auszeiten.
Das Jahr. Und damit man in der Zeit eben nicht die Daten verliert oder sagt, man hat jetzt gerade keine Satellitendaten für die Wettervorhersage, dann kann man diesen Backup-Sattelliten nutzen, der dann sozusagen heiß renontant einspringt.
Wie lange dauert das, wenn jetzt so angenommen ist gäbe jetzt einen Fehler? Also angenommen, es gäbe jetzt mal so richtig Error, ist ja vielleicht auch schon mal passiert, äh wie schnell kann man auf den anderen dann umschalten?
Das geht innerhalb von och ich würde mal sagen wenigen Stunden, ja, das sind ein, zwei Stunden. Ähm und dann muss natürlich die Maschinerie erstmal wieder synchronisiert werden. Aber die Technik an sich steht eigentlich, die ist heiß redundant, die steht eigentlich zur Verfügung.
Und warum gibt's jetzt noch diesen Blick auf den Indischen Ozean?
Ähm erst mal gibt's ähm natürlich äh den den Punkt, dass wir ähm,
ja, wenn wir von Deutschland aus schauen, wir haben im Indischen Ozean keine großen Interessen, ja, das interessiert uns nicht so wesentlich, aber wir haben ja als auch Frankreich und Großbritannien als Mitgliedslander zum Beispiel.
Und da gibt es durchaus äh sowohl in der Karibik, deswegen eine Ausdehnung nach Westen, als auch im indischen Ozean äh französische und britische Inseln und Gebiete, Territorien,
die einfach von diesen nationalen Wetterdiensten auch mit Wettervorhersagen versorgt werden müssen und darum ist äh die Abdeckung mit Satellitendaten auch in Richtung Indischer Ozean wichtig.
Stimmt, dass Europa größer ist, als man manchmal so denkt, da muss man nur auf die Banknoten drauf schauen. Da sind die nämlich alle eingezeichne.
Die ganzen Inseln, genau. Und dann dürfen wir nicht vergessen, das muss man einfach auch sagen, dass das Thema Flugwetter ja ein ganz wichtiges Element der Wettervorhersage ist.
Und äh Flugwetter,
ja wissen wir, dass es auch Richtung äh Afghanistan äh ein wichtiges Thema war auch für die für die Bundeswehr, aber natürlich auch für die anderen,
Länder, die dort im Einsatz beteiligt waren, das heißt, dort vorhersagen zu können, wie die Routen äh aussehen, aber eben bis in den Indischen Ozean hinein,
und auch die Unterstützung nicht zu vergessen der afrikanischen Wetterdienste, die ja auch vom indischen Ozean stark betroffen sind. Das waren alles Elemente zu sagen, wenn wir in Satelliten übrig haben,
Der funktioniert noch, dann schieben wir den mal in Richtung Indischen Ozean und können so die die Abdeckung ausdecken.
Der war noch über.
Der hat länger funktioniert, als wir das ursprünglich gedacht haben. Wenn wir.
Älteste von den Vieren. Genau. Mhm.
Genau. Wenn wir jetzt nur drei Satelliten hätten, dann würden wir wahrscheinlich den indischen Ozean nicht in der Form abdecken können,
Ähm aber das ist einfach möglich dadurch, dass die die Satelliten in ihrer Grundfunktion einfach sehr stabil und langlebig sind und darum konnten wir diese diesen Bereich der Abdeckung weiter ausdenken.
Einer von den vieren noch aus der ersten Generation.
Nein, die erste Generation ist nicht mehr da, es sind alles zweite Generationen.
Die ähm.
Dritte Generation. Also was hat sich jetzt so technisch wenn man jetzt mal erste auf zweite, zweite auf Dritte sieht so an den Instrumenarien?
Nennenswert verändert,
Also erste haben wir ja schon besprochen. Im Prinzip eine Abtastungszelle und ist ja gar nicht mal eine ganze Reihe, wie ich vorhin gesagt habe, ist ja eigentlich nur ein Punkt sozusagen mit dem Spiegel äh und mit der Rotation des Körpers. Das Prinzip
Ist aber auch noch bei der zweiten Generation beibehalten worden. Man konnte wahrscheinlich nur höher auflösen, feiner gucken.
Ist die zweite Generation auch eine reine optische Beobachtung oder wird da auch aus im Infrarotbereich äh empfangen, was.
Die Unterschiede.
Also ein wesentlicher wesentliche Weiterentwicklung der Kamera für die zweite Generation war dann tatsächlich, dass ein größerer Frequenzbereich ja, also mehr Farben ähm vermessen werden konnten.
Ähm da sind wir auf wesentlich mehr äh Frequenzbänder bis in den Infrarotbereich hin hineingegangen,
und äh der Infrarotbereich ist gerade sehr wichtig für das Thema Wasserdampf in der Atmosphäre. Also man kann ähm.
Nicht Wolken, die sind ja optisch gut zu sehen, ja, das sind ja quasi Tröpfchen von Wasser in Atmosphäre, sondern man kann den Wasserdampf,
in der Atmosphäre besonders gut im Infrarotenbereich sehen,
und das ist sozusagen das versteckte Wasser in der Atmosphäre, was dann später zu Wolkenbildung führen kann unter bestimmten atmosphärischen Bedingungen, deswegen war das für die Meteorologen wichtig, eben auch Informationen über die Verteilung des Wasserdampfes und die Sättigung,
der Atmosphäre mit Wasserdampf zu bekommen. Das war eine große Weiterentwicklung und bei der dritten Generation, bei MTG,
haben wir jetzt wieder eine Erweiterung der Frequenzbänder, das heißt, wir können feinere Bänder,
anschauen. Die sind schmaler geworden, schmalere Frequenzbänder, wir können also stärker differenzieren zwischen den unterschiedlichen Komponenten und den unterschiedlichen Wolkentypen.
Es geht stärker in den Bereich des Infraroten hinein,
aber die Auflösung, also die Pixel äh Auflösung der Bilder ist sehr viel feiner. Wir haben eine höhere Auflösung jetzt durch die neuen Satelliten.
Wie war's vorher? Wie ist es dann?
Na ja, wir waren vorher, glaube ich, im Bereich und jetzt nageln sie mich nicht auf die Zahlen fest, irgendwo im Bereich von zehn, zwölf Kilometer am Boden, für einen Punkt. Wir kommen jetzt in den Bereich von, ich glaube, um die vier Kilometer.
Mhm. Aus 36.000 Kilometern Entfernung.
Ganz genau, das muss man sich klar machen, ja, das ist also schon sozusagen die Fliege auf der Nase des äh 1hundert Meter-Läufers, der ins Ziel kommt, während man selbst noch im Startblock steht, sogar.
Wie viel Pixel, also ist es dann also ähm die Zweiten haben immer noch dieses Rotations Prinzip. Ähm das heißt, es ist halt eigentlich nur eine einzige Dichtzelle, die äh diese Punkte aufnimmt.
Oder sind das auch schon mehrere, um diese Pixel zu erzeugen.
Nein, das ist im Prinzip eine Abtastung von einem von einem Punkt am Boden, der aber, weil wir verschiedene Farben anschauen, mehrere Detektoren ja äh.
Okay, also das Licht von einem Punkt wird genommen und dann in verschiedenen äh Objektiven aufgebrochen und äh separat quasi ausgewertet.
Man kriegt so mehrere Informationsaksen pro Punkt, aber trotzdem schaut sich der Satellit streng genommen zu einem zu einer Zeiteinheit, immer nur einen einzigen Punkt an. Wie lange schaut der so üblicherweise auf so einen Punkt?
Also mit der Rotation und der Abtastung, mit dem Spiegel.
Dass er sich dreht, muss er ja immer sehr kurze Aufnahmen machen. Es würde ja die Information verschmiert werden über die Punkte. Also das sind dann tatsächlich so wie wir das kennen auch von von Aufnahmen auf der Erde.
Millisekunden.
Ja Millisekunden äh ist, glaube ich, dann sehr wenig, aber ich glaube.
Zehnte? Okay.
Bereich genau in der Richtung und äh mit der neuen Generation da haben wir jetzt tatsächlich ein Sensorfeld,
was dann äh die Erde nach und nach abtastet. Also es wird immer noch,
äh quasi die Erdoberfläche Stück für Stück abgetastet. Ähm und äh das passiert jetzt aber für für Felder.
Für viele Pixel sozusagen gleichzeitig. Also man hat so eine Matrix und wie groß ist diese Matrix? Wie viele Punkte werden da aufgenommen.
Das kann ich Ihnen gerade auswendig nicht sagen.
Hunderter, tausende Bereiche, also sind das nur sie jetzt ein paar mehr oder ist es gleich was ganz Großes?
Ähm nein, also wir haben ähm zum Beispiel äh die Abdeckung des des oberen Viertels der Erde,
die passiert ja kann man sagen ganz grob über,
rund 40 Felder, die wird in rund 40 Felder aufgeteilt und äh das heißt ein so ein Feld ist dann in der Größe ungefähr. Hm, das sind,
Ich glaube, wenn mich alles täuscht, so hundertsechzig mal hundert1sechzig Pixel pro Feld, die dann aufgelöst werden.
Also die die Pixelzahl an sich ist da nicht so entscheidend wie bei,
Fotoapparaten, die wir hier auf der Erde verwenden, sondern die Sensibilität der Pixel, die Genauigkeit, der Messwerte und natürlich die Auflösung in die verschiedenen Spektralen-Bereiche, die wir erreichen können.
Ist ja, ist ja auch so dieser alter Pixel-Mythos auch bei Kameras. Lange Zeit gab's so diese Wahrnehmung. Eine Kamera ist automatisch dadurch besser, dass sie irgendwie mehr Pixel aufteilt, aber das heißt ja dann auch immer, es fällt weniger Licht auf den Sensor und das
dass die Messungen dann äh ist oder länger belichten muss, um überhaupt erstmal ein akzeptables Ergebnis zu bekommen und wenn man jetzt hier so
Time constraint äh ist, also quasi das Ding rotiert sich halt einfach, man will da drauf schauen
Ist es ja sinnvoll, möglichst große Pixel zu haben oder in dem Fall, wo man eben viele, wenn man noch mal so eine Unterteilung hat, sollten die natürlich alle einzeln auch äh groß äh sein.
Aber äh ja können dann eben trotzdem das
wahrscheinlich nochmal etwas differenzierter betrachten und man kann mehr Nuancen äh nochmal äh aus diesem.
Aus diesem virtuellen großen äh Pixel herausziehen.
Mhm. Ja genau. Also deswegen ist nicht so sehr die hohe Pixelanzahl für uns relevant, sondern mehr, wie gesagt, die Qualität.
Genau. Wie wie genau ist das? Wie viel Licht macht das? Ist das äh Technologie, die dann auch hier entwickelt wird oder wer baut diese Satelliten? Designt, diese.
Also wir haben tatsächlich zwei große Gruppen ähm zur Industriegruppen, die äh in Europa in der Lage sind, solche Instrumente zu entwickeln.
Das eine ist eine äh es sind beides deutsch-französische Industriegruppen.
Und ähm tatsächlich wird äh wird hier, wenn die Metrosatz,
äh von einer äh der Gruppen äh entwickelt. Da sitzt äh die französische äh das französische Unternehmen in Cannes an der Mittelmeerküste und das deutsche Unternehmen sitzt in Bremen.
Und äh die entwickeln gemeinsam diese Satelliten und auch die Instrumente, die beiden Hauptinstrumente, also diese Kameras, die auf den Satelliten sitzen.
Und äh das ist äh natürlich mit vielen Komponenten aus vielen europäischen Ländern, ja, also das äh wird nicht alles im im eigenen Hause entwickelt. Da werden bestimmte Sensoren, bestimmte Teile der Optik,
die Filter, die Beschichtung der Filter et cetera, werden also in vielen Ländern dann jeweils äh entwickelt und und zugekauft,
einige Teile kommen tatsächlich auch insbesondere, was die Beschichtung von Filtern angeht und von von Strahlteilern, wie man sie nennt, kommen zum Teil auch aus den USA, aber der Anteil der USA der US-Technik ist,
immer weiter runtergegangen. Also wir sind mittlerweile in Europa kann man sagen weltweit ähm,
unter den Führenden, ich sage nicht immer, wir sind führend, das klingt dann immer so so blasphemisch, aber wir gehören zu den führenden Regionen.
Der Spitzengruppe mit.
Da können brauchen wir uns nicht zu verstecken von niemandem, auch von den Amerikanern nicht, dass wir derartige Instrumente sehr gut in Europa entwickeln können mit nahezu allem, was wir dazu brauchen.
Wie läuft denn das konkret ab? Äh können ja mal diese dritte Generation nehmen, weil das ist ja jetzt im Prinzip genau das, was in Betrieb genommen wird. Ähm,
Gut, solche Wünsche und äh Vorstellungen, was man dann in einer nächsten Generation mal so machen könnte, das ist ja wahrscheinlich so ein permanenter Vorgang und äh man sitzt jeden Tag da und denkt sich, hätten wir nur ig so ne?
Dann aber ab wann hat sich das dann konsolidiert. Also wenn die jetzt nächstes Jahr starten, wann.
Hat dieses Design konkret das Design dieser dritten Generation begonnen und mit wem wer spricht sich da jetzt erstmal mit wem darüber ab, was man eigentlich will? Wer macht dieses Anforderungsprofil?
Das ist ein ganz wichtiges Verfahren im Vorfeld, bevor man überhaupt anfängt, irgendeine Schraube,
an so einem Satelliten zu entwickeln. Das ist tatsächlich ein ganz intensiver Dialog zwischen den Meterologen und Klimaforschern und allen denen, die diese Daten später nutzen sollen.
Und uns Ingenieuren hier. Dazu sind sozusagen unsere Experten hier bei äh insbesondere auf der Instrumentenseite wichtig,
Und wir haben dort einen sehr intensiven Dialog, um erstmal rauszufinden, was möchtet ihr denn gern an Daten, in welcher Genauigkeit, in welcher Wiederholrate.
Über welchen Zeitraum überhaupt haben, damit es euch hilft.
So permanente Arbeitsgruppen oder macht man das eher über so Konferenzen, dass man sagt, so jetzt treffen wir uns mal und dann müsst ihr mal eure Anforderungen vorlegen und dann sprechen wir mal drüber.
Also es gibt natürlich permanente wissenschaftliche Beratergremien für alle Missionen. Ja die gucken sich das an und schauen, was man aus den Daten alles rausholen kann. Auch während die Missionen schon fliegen.
Auch die heutige zweite Generation an Meteorosatz
hat ein enormes Potenzial noch in ihren Daten. Durch die Langfristigkeit, durch die Stabilität, durch die Genauigkeit der Daten wird sie immer wichtiger, nicht nur für Wettervorhersage, ja, das war dann ja vielleicht schon gestern.
Vor allem für Klimaentwicklung.
Für Klimaentwicklung und da wird immer mehr ausgewertet, auch aus den früheren Wetterdaten, die wir zum Glück abgespeichert und archiviert haben, die wir jetzt wieder vorholen können. Wir können also rückwärts rechnen,
Ja und vergleichbare Situationen vor ein paar Jahren betrachten und dann schauen, wie sich das langfristig ändert. Also insofern gibt's diese wissenschaftlichen Beratergremien permanent. Natürlich. Aber.
Sobald wir sagen die die laufende Generation der Satelliten,
kann demnächst abgelöst werden durch eine neue Generation, dann machen wir sozusagen nochmal einen konkreten Aufpunkt,
für die Wissenschaftler, Meteorologen, Klimaforscher et cetera und sagen so und jetzt fassen wir das mal zusammen. Jetzt schreiben wir das mal fest, denn wie Sie schon gesagt haben, es geht natürlich permanent die Entwicklung weiter, der Wissenschaft, aber muss irgendwann einfach mal auch festschreiben,
was man in den Satelliten äh realisieren möchte, sonst hat man eine permanent veränderliche Basis auf der Basis kann man keine Instrumente entwickeln, ja? Irgendwann muss man mal sagen so, das ist es jetzt und das versuchen wir zu entwickeln.
So und in diesem Prozess gibt es ein wichtiges Dokument. Das ist das Endnutzer äh Anforderungsdokument.
Da steht drin, was der Satelliten alles an Daten liefern können soll.
Und das ein kontrolliertes Dokument. Das ist mit den Wissenschaftlern abgesprochen. Das wird auch immer wieder äh reviewt.
Und durchgeprüft, aber das dient als Basis für die Entwicklung der der Instrumente.
Und das ist jetzt für die neue Generation, für MTG hat man das so zweitausendacht, zweitausendneun, zweitausendzehn,
ähm zusammengeschrieben und festgeschrieben und das dient seitdem für die Entwicklung der Instrumente. Ähm dann gibt's erstmal.
2008 hat man im Prinzip angefangen, die erste Spezifikation für die neue Generation zu machen.
Genau und dann gibt's einen Ausgleich natürlich äh und Absprachen mit vielen Kreisen an Wissenschaftlern. Äh auch die müssen sich ja erst mal ein gemeinsames Bild machen. Man kann nicht alles realisieren. Manche Werte muss man dann leider wieder aufgeben, weil's nicht realisierbar ist.
Ähm die Instrumente ähm können ja auch äh wie gesagt, ergibt ja einen begrenzten Platz auf so einem Satelliten, ja, es können auch nicht alle möglichen Instrumente drauf. Von daher dieser Auswahlprozess ist schon relativ langwierig.
Aber das geht dann quasi als Anforderungsdokument in die Industrie und dort wird gesagt, wir brauchen ein Instrument, das Folgendes kann.
Wir brauchen einen Satellitensystem, ja, mit der Übertragung der Daten zum Boden, mit der Auswertung der Daten, mit der mit der Prozessierungssoftware und so weiter, die diese Daten innerhalb von einer Zeit X.
Durchrechnet und den Nutzern zur Verfügung stellt. Auch das ist ja ein wichtige Anforderung, wie schnell die Daten beim Nutzer sein müssen und das ist bei uns eine der treibenden Kräfte hinter unserem System.
Innerhalb von einer halben Stunde zum Beispiel die Satellitendaten beim Nutzer haben möchten.
Wie bei der Isar, wurde erst mal gesammelt wird und dann kriegen das dann irgendwann die Wissenschaftler und dann denke ich mal ein paar Monate drüber nach, sondern hier liegt der Wert einfach in der Echtzeit äh Weiterleitung.
Ja natürlich, also wenn man eine eine eine Supernova äh beobachtet, ja und auswertet, was da passiert ist, dann ist es egal, ob das in diesem oder im nächsten Jahr passiert oder in fünf Jahren, das ist ganz klar. Aber bei Wetter kommt's eben drauf an, das Jetzt zu machen.
Klima ist wieder eine andere Geschichte,
Klima kommt auf die Stabilität und die Archivierbarkeit der Daten an. Das heißt, wir müssen sie wiederfinden und sie müssen auch in einer gleichbleibenden Qualität abgespeichert werden, sodass man sie auch nach ein paar Jahren wiederfindet und hervorholen kann und nachberechnen kann.
So, zweitausendacht ging's los, ähm dann wurden irgendwann die bauenden Unternehmen beauftragt, dann wurde halt gesagt, so hier, das hätten wir gerne, dann haben die kurz drüber gelacht wahrscheinlich und gesagt so
schön wär's, aber hier folgende Konstrains und Geld und Größe und Gewicht und was nicht alles, äh dann ist das wahrscheinlich dann so ein äh fortwährendes hin und her und dann sagt man ja okay, gut, dann äh haben wir's hier vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, aber wie wär's denn damit und dann findet man irgendwo so den Kompromiss
wann sind dann die wann ist dann diese Generation quasi technisch abgesegnet worden? Wann stand das Profil fest? Was man jetzt genau bauen möchte.
Ja, das war so zweitausendvierzehn, zweitausendfünfzehn,
durch diesen Prozess durch. Da spielt ja die die europäische Raumfolgeagentur, die ESA, eine ganz wichtige Rolle, weil das die Spezialisten sind, die dann sicherstellen können, dass so ein Satellit unseren Instrument tatsächlich auch entwickelt werden kann.
Wir haben zwar die die Spezialisten, die die Anforderungen der Meteorologen in eine Anforderung an Instrumente übersetzen können, ja? Also diese Interface, das bilden wir.
Aber wie man ein Instrument so qualifiziert, dass es im Weltraum auch zehn Jahre hält und funktionieren.
Auch nur den Staat überlebt.
Staat überlebt und so weiter. Das sind wieder andere Experten, das ist auch eine Spezialdisziplin von Raumfahrtingenieuren,
haben wir hier nicht nochmal dupliziert, weil die gibt's ja schon bei der Isar. Man hat von Anfang an gesagt, das ist dann der Punkt, wo wir an die Isar übergeben, sozusagen, die kriegen dann von uns,
Ein Mandat.
Für uns diese Satelliten zu entwickeln. Und das macht die Isar. Wir sind da in engen Kontakt. Wir machen auch permanent äh haben wir haben wir unsere Meetings und und äh informieren uns gegenseitig, ähm wie die Anforderungsseite, aber auch die,
Satellitenentwicklung vorwärts geht und dann übergibt die Esa, die fertig entwickelten und gebauten Satelliten an uns,
sodass wir sie dann starten und betreiben können. Das ist dies Zusammenspiel zwischen Eumelsad und Esa. Deswegen sind wir da natürlich äh nicht ganz so äh bekannt und vielleicht auch nicht ganz so technologisch,
äh berühmt wie die Isar, die solche Satelliten entwickeln kann, aber äh das ist eine ganz wichtige Zusammenarbeit. Ohne die könnten wir auch nicht existieren.
Das heißt, die ganzen Satelliten gehen dann vermutlich auch irgendwann mal zum Estech nach Holland, um dort äh ihre finale Absiedlung zu erhalten, bevor sie dann.
Was immer gelauncht werden, äh werden alle Meteorosat Satelliten mit äh Ariane-Systemen gestartet.
Also die die Satelliten heutzutage hat man das tatsächlich glücklicherweise so, dass die,
Industrie, die sie entwickelt ähm dann auch testen kann endgültig testen kann und äh sie gehen dann direkt vom Hauptauftragnehmer, also in diesem Falle aus Cannes oder aus Bremen,
auf dem Schiff und werden von dort nach verschickt, also in Französisch-Guyana.
Kommen nicht nicht ins und werden da nicht nochmal auf Herz und Nieren.
Die nicht mehr, die nicht mehr. Es gibt andere Satelliten, die werden immer noch in Asdak getestet, aber die dann nicht mehr.
Mhm. Okay.
Und ähm die werden dort tatsächlich mit einer Ariane gestartet, ja. Also die Meteorosatz sind äh bis jetzt alle mit einer Ariane gestartet worden.
Wir haben für die Sonnensynchronensatelliten, das ist ja eine andere Familie, ja die niedrig Fliegenden äh Satelliten, die diesen polaren Orbit haben.
Noch gar nicht so erwähnt haben.
Noch gar nicht erwähnt. Genau, die fliegen dann auch mit einer Rakete, das ist eine etwas kleinere Rakete, die müssen ja nicht ganz so hoch. Ähm aber die Großen.
Aber auch in Corona, ne.
Auch von Corona, ja. Die Großen zum geostationären fliegen alle mit der Ariane.
Ariane fünf oder Ariane sechs?
Noch Ariane fünf. Gibt ja noch keine Ariane sechs, aber wir sind natürlich ganz gespannt drauf. Ähm aber auch hier wieder, da wir natürlich unsere Satelliten gern auch heil in den Orbit.
Möchte man nicht auf den ersten Ariana sechs Start. Wir gucken uns das zwei-, dreimal an und dann nehmen wir einen, der der nachfolgenden.
Der funktioniert. Wir nehmen den, der funktioniert. Ähm,
Grade schon äh erwähnt, jetzt haben wir also viel über diese Meteorosat-Generation gesprochen. Die erste, die alles begonnen hat, die zweite, die derzeit die Realität darstellt und die Dritte, die quasi alles nochmal viel äh toller und schöner und bunter macht.
Trotzdem gibt's noch diese zweite Serie der Low Orbit, Polar äh Sonnensynchronen äh Satelliten. Die laufen hier unter mit.
Seit wann gibt es die und inwiefern ergänzen die jetzt das Spiel?
Ja, das sind ähm Satelliten, die ja aufgrund ihrer Umlaufbahn nicht,
Eine Halbkugel der Erde permanent im Blick haben, sondern die quasi einen Streifen, den sie gerade überfliegen, vermessen und die erst durch die,
Durch das Überfliegen der Erde und durch die Rotation der Erde drunter durch quasi im Laufe eines Tages dann die ganze Erde abdecken können.
Und das ist eine Ergänzung dahingehend, dass wir hier ein europäisches System haben, was tatsächlich die Wetter-und klimarelevanten Daten weltweit,
messen kann. Die machen das aufgrund ihres Orbits immer morgens um neun Uhr dreißig, also an jedem Ort,
der Welt bekommen wir sozusagen die Daten für 9 Uhr dreißig morgens, die Amerikaner haben eine andere Umlaufbahn, die Chinesen haben auch solche Satelliten, die haben wieder eine andere Zeit, sodass man in der Kombination,
wieder international der verschiedenen äh sich ergänzenden Satellitensysteme ein Bild der ganzen Welt zu verschiedenen Uhrzeiten am Tag bekommt.
Das ist natürlich ähm eine eine interessante Ergänzung.
Der zweite Punkt, der ähm hier ergänzend wirkt ist, dass diese Satelliten in der Höhe von,
800 bis 1000 Kilometern fliegen, nicht in 36.000 Kilometer Höhe und das macht schon einen Unterschied, auch in der Auflösung der Messwerte auf.
Wir haben also hier eine eine höhere Auflösung in diesem Streifen, der da vermessen wird,
und wir können auch noch ganz andere Parameter messen, auch äh Luftbestandteile, nicht nur wetterrelevante Daten, physikalische Daten wie Luftdruck, Feuchtigkeit, Temperatur et cetera, sondern wir können hier auch,
Stickoxide, Kohlenmonoxid, Schwefeloxide und so weiter. Also atmosphärische Bestandteile messen. Wir kann Aerosole, also Staub in der Atmosphäre vermessen, zum Beispiel aus Vulkanausbrüchen, aber auch von Industrieaktivitäten.
Da kommen dann plötzlich Luftqualität Aspekte mit hinein. Und das ist ganz wichtig, um,
ähm auch über das Jahr eben die die Qualität der Luft in Europa in Ballungszentren zum Beispiel, das Mikroklima in städtischen Ballungsräumen,
ähm äh auswerten zu können,
auch Maßnahmen zum zur Sicherung der Luftqualität oder zur Verbesserung der Luftqualität können dadraus abgeleitet werden und man kann überwachen, ob die tatsächlich umgesetzt werden und was die bringen. Das ist nochmal eine eine ganz andere Dimension, die hier mit hineinkommt.
Das Flugwetter durfte an der Stelle eine Rolle spielen, da wird man ja immer ganz hellhörig, wenn man einen Vulkanausbruch äh hört, wir erinnern uns ja alle noch an den Ausbruch äh des oder aus sprechlichen Vulkans in äh Island, der Name, der nicht genannt werden soll, weil keiner ihn aussprech,
kann ähm da war ja die das mit der Flugasche so extrem, dass ja wirklich ein äh ein Stopp äh ähm,
des Flugbetriebs ausgerufen wurde. Ähm ist man dann da eigentlich also.
An so einem interessanten Punkt, weil wir haben's ja schon gesagt, okay, eigentlich geht's ums Wetter und es ist eine Dienstleistung und es geht darum
schnell diese Daten zu liefern. Aber natürlich kriegen die Daten jetzt auch im Bereich der Klimaforschung eine extreme Bedeutung, insbesondere weil man eben so einen langen
zeitlichen Verlauf hat und da hatten ja manchmal einfach dadurch äh erst interessant werden, dass man eben sehr viele davon hat und sie kontinuierlich hat.
Parallel hat ja die ESA aber auch schon immer sehr stark auf Erd
Beobachtung gesetzt und in gewisser Hinsicht ist das ja hier eine sehr überschneidende Tätigkeit, also insbesondere die Kopernikus äh Metamission der Esa, habe ich hier bei Raumzeit auch schon viel drüber berichtet. Hier sind diese einzelnen Sentinel.
Satelliten in den letzten Jahren schon gestartet worden. Manche kommen noch. Jeder einzelne Satellit oder jedes Pärchen übernimmt so eine bestimmte weiteren Blick und beobachtet ja eben auch viele dieser Aspe
die wir gerade angesprochen haben, die jetzt quasi auch diese Methop äh Satelliten machen. Inwiefern sind diese Methop,
ähm Satelliten mit in diesen Erdbeobachtungskosmos, der Esa mit eingebunden oder es hat was Separates, arbeitet man da äh zusammen, was,
was für eine Rolle spielt quasi Olmed satt bei der eigentlichen Erdbeobachtung, die jetzt eigentlich primär nicht für Wetter gedacht ist?
Ähm das ist eine sehr komplexe Frage. Jetzt muss ich erstmal gucken, ob ich die wieder so in Gänze zusammenbekomme, damit ich da eine einfache Antwort drauf formulieren kann.
Ähm also das das Kopernikus-Programm erstmal ist tatsächlich äh enorm wichtig,
für Europa. Vielleicht sollten wir davon mal ausgehen und dann mal gucken, wie ist unser Verhältnis äh,
mit mit Zwischenräumezeit und den anderen Partnern. Zunächst mal wer mir nochmal wichtig festzuhalten, dass das Kopernikusprogramm nicht in erster Linie ein Programm der Isar ist, sondern ein Programm der Europäischen Union.
Kommission. Ich glaube ähm wir wir suchen ja immer nach Möglichkeiten irgendwie der Europäischen Kommission am Zeug zu flicken, weil wir den immer vorwerfen. Sie würden irgendwie die Bananen definieren und die Gurken,
Ähm aber de facto hat die Europäische Kommission, die Europäische Union,
hier ein Programm aufgelegt vor vielen, vielen Jahren schon. Ähnlich übrigens wie Galileo, das Navigations äh System äh von äh von Europa. Was wirklich weltweit Standards setzt,
ähm diese dieses Programm, was die die Europäische Kommission dort aufgelegt hat und was durch die Esa natürlich realisiert wird, weil die Isar die Satelliten entwickelt.
Setzt Maßstäbe weltweit für Erdbeobachtungsdaten und vor allen Dingen für die Verfügbarkeit und die freie Verfügbarkeit von Erdbeobachtungsdaten. Eins der für mich wichtigsten Ergebnisse dieses Kopernikus Programms.
Dass diese Daten der Öffentlichkeit, der Wissenschaft,
aber auch für Industrie, für kommerzielle Anwendungen, für die Landwirtschaft, für die Fischerei, für die Sehschifffahrt, für die Flug äh Wirtschaft.
Kostenlos und permanent zur Verfügung stehen.
An der Stelle muss ich äh kurz Werbung machen für Raumzeit neunundsechzig, wo ich mich mit Bianca Hirsch äh unterhalten habe über die Kopernikus Open Datas, da äh,
schon sehr viel über dieses Thema gekommen und ja klar, ganz klar, das ist ein zentrales Element, ein definierendes Element auch der Koperikus-Mission.
Und ich glaube, da da können wir Europäer auch ein klein bisschen stolz auf uns sein, dass wir hier weltweit auch die Fahne hochhalten für diese freie Verfügbarkeit von Daten, weil es durchaus auch andere Regionen in der Welt gibt,
solche Daten als Hoheitswissen gerne auch für sich behalten würden oder als Wirtschaftsgut,
bestenfalls gegen andere Wirtschaftsgüter tauschen möchten, ja, also die dem geldwerten Vorteil beimessen und dann äh unter Verschluss halten und bestenfalls verkaufen oder tauschen wollen. Also da sind, glaube ich, wir Europäer,
ähm ausnahmsweise darf man das mal sagen, äh auch mal auf der guten Seite hier und gerade die Europäische Kommission äh macht hier wirklich einen sehr, sehr guten Job.
Ähm und äh ja diese diese Daten sind für so viele Leute eben wichtig, genauso wie die Wetter- und Klimadaten.
Dass wir jetzt ein ein Trend sehen, dass das zunehmend zusammenfließt. Also wir haben ja,
auf der äh Datenverarbeitungsseite auch ein ganz interessanten Trend, nicht nur durch das Internet, was also die die Verschiebung von Daten zwischen verschiedenen Punkten ermöglicht,
sondern auch durch das Cloud-Computing, durch Big Data ähm haben wir jetzt eine Situation, dass man Daten zentral hält,
und dort verarbeiten kann und nicht mehr die Daten hin und her schieben muss, um sie irgendwo lokal zu verarbeiten,
und dieser äh diese Entwicklung äh hat auch einen ganz großen Einfluss darauf, wie Erdbeobachtungsdaten ähm bereits jetzt aber auch in Zukunft noch immer stärker,
ähm genutzt werden und zur Verfügung gestellt werden. Es gibt also im Rahmen des Kopernikusprogramms ähm.
Plattformen, Cloudsysteme, auf denen diese Daten liegen und dort eingesehen oder genutzt werden können.
Und ähm um äh ja auch ein Beispiel zu nennen. Wir sind von gemeinsam mit zwei anderen Partnern an dem Betrieb einer solchen Plattform beteiligt und haben das mit aufgebaut, was sich jetzt speziell auf,
Wetter,
Meeresforschungsatmosphärische Daten konzentriert. Also wenn man solche Daten sucht, dann würde man die in einer solchen Cloud finden. Es gibt noch andere Clouds, die sich dann mehr auf,
landrelevante Daten äh äh konzentrieren, wie sie für die Landwirtschaft zum Beispiel.
Vermessung, genau. Mhm. Stadtplanerische Daten auch.
Genau. Genau und den gibt es äh noch eine weitere Initiative. Wir tun uns jetzt grade mit anderen Partnern zusammen zum Beispiel,
ähm um eine äh eine sogenannte zu bilden. Das heißt, dort wollen wir alle Wetter- und klimarelevanten Daten, die wir von diesen Partnern bekommen, auch zentral zur Verfügung stellen.
Und ähm als vielleicht letzte, sehr sehr spannende Initiative, wie ich finde,
hat die Europäische Kommission, die Esa und wir,
jetzt eine eine Initiative gestartet, die sich Destination Earth nennt,
Ähm dort geht es darum ähm für die Zukunft,
Simulationsmodelle von Wetter oder von Erdsystemen zu erstellen. Das heißt, man versucht die Erde und ihr Verhalten digital zu simulieren,
einen sozusagen digitalen Zwilling zu etablieren,
zum Beispiel das Wettersystem, also die Atmosphäre, digital repräsentiert ist und dort mit Daten gefüttert wird,
Dieser digitale Zwilling der Erde wird im Moment ähm aufgebaut und da können wir in den nächsten Jahren Entwicklung sehen, dass alle diese Daten,
die wir eben durch die Satelliten generieren, aber auch aus anderen äh Beobachtungssystemen in dieses digitale Modell mit einfließen und sozusagen dann von allen eingesehen und auch genutzt werden können.
Das heißt, man sieht hier auch schon eine Evolution eigentlich auch dieser Dienstleistung und ich denke, das ist auch halt glaube ich etwas, was man an der Stelle nochmal betonen muss. Ich denke Ometz hat versteht sich
primär sozusagen als als Dienstleister, einer einer Wissenschaft äh Gemeinde auf der einen Seite, aber eben auch den
den Wetterdiensten, die in konkreten unmittelbaren gesellschaftlichen und wirtschaftlichen Nutzen haben und und dem ist ja hier im Prinzip erst mal alles untergeordnet. Das,
definiert die Ausrichtung, das definiert die Anwendung und all diese Kooperationen mit den Forschungs äh Bereichen, die kommen da noch mit hinzu.
Und wenn man jetzt mal quasi so dieses alte Bild des des Polaroids
ja, das das der abfotografierte äh Bildschirm, das mehr oder weniger
Beobachtungsfotos der Wolken, der ersten Satellitengeneration nimmt und das äh jetzt mal mit dieser Wezher Cloud hinten zusteht, dann ist das ja sozusagen auch eine
Verschiebung der Auswertung dieser Daten. Also wenn man sagt, man stellt die Daten zur Verfügung in einer Weather Cloud, dann meint man ja nicht, man stellt dieselben Daten nur an einem anderen Ort zur Verfügung, sondern das hat auch was mit Aufbereitung, Selektion und,
auch schon ein paar Ebenen von Interpretation, dass man eben nicht unbedingt sich jetzt,
an jeder Stelle nochmal durch die Rohdaten durcharbeiten muss, weil es ja auch einfach viel zu viel ist, sondern die Daten werden aggregiert, interpretiert und in schon mal in Modelle äh gepackt, sodass man sie auch leichter auswerten kann. Habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Absolut, genau. Also das äh ähm das Gute an diesem äh an diesem Cloud-System ist eben, dass man die Rohdaten nicht immer nur hin und her transportieren muss, um sie dann immer wieder neu anzufassen.
Sondern dass man die die Interpretationsalgorithmen, also die Software, die aus den Rohdaten tatsächlich Informationen macht,
man die auf diesen Rohdaten laufen lassen kann, auf diesen Cloudsystem. Hier spielen die äh nationalen Wetterdienste eine ganz ganz wichtige Rolle.
Neben den Reihen Wettervorhersagen, die sie ja täglich machen, haben wir mit unseren.
Mitgliedsländern, also mit den Wetterdiensten unserer Mitgliedsländer. Wir haben ja 30 Mitgliedsländer in, muss man nochmal dazu sagen, ja, also wir haben von Island bis zur Türkei und von Norwegen bis Portugal und alles dazwischen, sind Mitgliedsländer von,
und haben sozusagen das Nutzungsrecht an diesen Daten, aber sie tragen durch ihre Kompetenz und durch ihre Forschungseinrichtungen und durch ihre Spezialitäten dazu bei, dass sich auch.
Unsere Auswertungsalgorithmen entsprechend weiterentwickeln,
Wir haben da die das sogenannte Netzwerk der Satellite Application Facilities oder Suff Kurzgarant, SAF.
Ähm wo sich einzelne Wetterdienste zusammentun, ja? Eine Handvoll von nationalen Wetterdiensten, die sich für einen bestimmten Bereich besonders interessieren und dort eine besondere Kompetenz entwickeln und daher auch dort bestimmte.
Auswerte Algorithmen besonders weiterentwickeln. Ja also wir haben ein eine Gruppe von Wetterdiensten die sich besonders um.
Zum Beispiel Waldbrände kümmert oder die sich besonders um die Luftqualität kümmert oder die sich besonders um äh hydrologische Fragen kümmert.
So gibt es verschiedene Schwerpunkte und diese Gruppe von Saffs ähm entwickeln als sozusagen Kompetenzzentren, diese auswerte Algorithmen weiter und stellen sie dann aber der gesamten Gemeinschaft zur Verfügung.
In das Netz ein und wenn Sie so ein Cloudsystem haben, also eine Datenplattform,
der diese auswerte Algorithmen laufen können, dann ist es natürlich viel einfacher sozusagen diese Daten auch zu nutzen und rechtzeitig schnell auszuwerten mit den bestmöglichen auswerte Software, die gerade in der wissenschaftlichen Welt verfügbar sind.
Erstens muss man sich das Rad neu erfinden, was manchmal ganz schön lange dauert, weil manche Räder sind kompliziert,
Man ist mehr oder weniger automatisch immer auf dem aktuellen Stand der Forschung, was eben die Interpretation dieser Daten betrifft. Und es sind ja dann auch sehr viel weniger Daten, mit denen man überhaupt noch arbeiten muss, weil man im Prinzip schon diesen Extrakt nimmt und quasi so eine logische Aussage bekommt.
So unterstützen sich diese 30 Mitgliedsländer bei gegenseitig mit ihren jeweiligen Kompetenzen. Nicht jeder muss alles machen, sondern man spezialisiert sich im Bereich und hat dann Zugriff auf alle anderen Kompetenzen.
Und wie koexistiert das jetzt mit den Kopernikus Mission?
Also die die Senti Nails ähm sind äh erstmal ein ein ein Beobachtungs,
System, ja, das ist eine Gruppe von Satelliten, die jeweils jeder Satellit hat, so seine speziellen Instrumente und spezielle Schwerpunkte,
Es gibt optische Satelliten, es gibt Radarsatelliten, ähm es gibt Satelliten, die auch im Infrarotbereich arbeiten, um Mikrowellen et cetera.
Und die unterschiedliche Bereiche aufnehmen. Das ist also eine Familie,
wir haben jetzt sechs Senti Nails die definiert sind. Ein siebter ist jetzt gerade in Entwicklung. In ein paar Jahren kommen noch weitere Sentinel Satelliten dazu, die alle unterschiedliche Schwerpunkte haben.
Wie ich eben schon erwähnte, je nach Beobachtungsschwerpunkt und äh ja Anwendungsbereich der Daten, die von diesen Satelliten generiert werden,
die ausgewertet durch die verschiedenen ähm wissenschaftlichen Institute, die sich mit dieser Thematik besonders beschäftigen. Wir bei haben nach wie vor den Schwerpunkt der Wetter- und Klimaforschung.
Und da gibt es im Moment auch keine Sentinailsatelliten, die jetzt parallel zu uns, Wetter oder Klimadaten vermessen,
Die Sentinels beziehen sich auf Erdbeobachtung, ja, also äh mit Radardaten, mit Bilder, mit Mikrowellen et cetera.
Aber das ist ein ergänzendes System. Also unsere Wettersatelliten und Klimasatelliten,
und auch zum Beispiel ein Satellit, der jetzt die Meereshöhe vermisst, ja, ergänzt sich mit den mit den Daten des Senti Nails, sodass quasi das eine große europäische Familie an Satelliten ist, die insgesamt alle Bereiche der Erdbeobachtung ab.
Das heißt, einfach formuliert die Satelliten und die äh ganzen äh Softwareanwendungen, die noch mit dazugekommen ergänzen. Das Kopernikus Programm mit ihrer spezifischen Wetter-äh,
Expertise und Brille und äh reich an das gesamte System dadurch noch weiter an.
Ja, genau, so kann man das sagen.
Das heißt auch, dass generell die Daten alle so verfügbar sind, wie das bei Kopernikus ist, also ist diese selber open Data Strategie generell bei.
Absolut wichtig, wie ich vorhin schon erwähnte, sind wir ja auch beteiligt, zusammen mit der Ese, aber auch mit anderen Partnern. Solche Cloud-Systemen zu realisieren,
Da sind eben nicht nur unsere Daten drauf, sondern da sind auch Sentinell Daten drauf, sodass man tatsächlich die, ich sage mal, das Fernziel wäre, dass ein Nutzer,
sich äh in eine ein solches Cloudsystem einloggt, auf eine solche Plattform einloggt und ohne, dass er merkt, von welchem Server,
zu welchem Server er sich da nun verbindet, sondern dass er mit einer Nutzeroberfläche im Grunde genommen alle Datenarten von Daten,
greifen kann und auch auf die Archive zugreifen kann. Das ist so ein bisschen das Fernziel. Aber dieses Fernziel ist gar nicht so weit weg. Also wir reden ja hier tatsächlich von wenigen Jahren.
Realisiert werden soll, denn die Systeme sind in ihrer Grundfunktion schon entwickelt,
Im Moment sind alle Partner dabei, ihre Daten auf solche Systeme zu transferieren und es geht jetzt hier in erster Linie um eine,
föderale Struktur dieser verschiedenen,
Archive, sodass man als Nutzer quasi nur eine Oberfläche hat, aber welche Einzelarchive da drunter liegen gar nicht mehr wahrnimmt und sich auch gar nicht mehr drum zu kümmern, wo auch, sondern man greift dann auf das Archiv zu, wo die Daten halt grade liegen.
Nutzer werden.
Ja selbstverständlich, man kann sich im Internet tatsächlich anmelden, auch als Privatnutzer. Ähm natürlich,
ein bisschen Expertise schadet nicht bei der Auswertung der Daten, aber ähm das kann äh jede jedes Uni-Institut, jeder Privatnutzer, jedes Forschungsinstitut, jeder nationale Wetterdienst, äh die können das machen.
Wie gesagt, die europäischen Daten sind tatsächlich frei verfügbar und äh können dort eingesehen werden.
Auch statt, also gibt's da einen Hair von Hobby, Meteorologen, die da äh äh selber ihre eigenen Auswertungen machen?
Na, ich glaube, Hobby-Meteorologen haben wir genauso viele wie Hobbybunde für die Fußball-Nationalmannschaft. Ähm also da sind wahrscheinlich.
Ja. Die wissen auch immer richtig Bescheid.
Natürlich. Jeder macht seine eigene Wettervorhersage meistens noch am besten.
Man sieht das ja im astronomischen Bereich, man ist ja durchaus so, dass äh die die Amateure äh.
Einfach etwas mitbringen, was was äh quasi die Profis oft nicht haben, nämlich irgendwie die Zeit und die Ruhe sich auf irgendwas äh super Spezielles zu konzentrieren und äh ja schon viele Asteroiden und äh andere Himmelskörper äh auch von Amateuren ähm.
Entdeckt worden, gibt's im meteorologischen Bereich auch so Nischen, die ja jetzt vielleicht auch für den Wetterdiensten so erstmal nicht abgedeckt werden und wo noch ein bisschen Potenzial ist für so.
Ich bin jetzt nicht ähm in einem Wetterdienst, aber was mir auffällt,
ist, dass äh Wetterdienste zunehmend dazu übergehen, ähm sich auch Rückmeldungen zu holen.
Aus der Bevölkerung. Also wenn wir zum Beispiel den Deutschen Wetterdienst annehmen, ist ja ein äh,
sehr, sehr fortschrittlicher und moderner Wetterdienst, der der auch äh in dem Bereich der numerischen Wettervorhersage und der digitalen Kommunikation sehr fortgeschritten ist,
Die haben eine wirklich tolle App entwickelt und diese App des Deutschen Wetterdienstes.
Erlaubt jedem Einzelnen eine Rückmeldung zu geben, ja zu dem Wetter. Was beobachte ich grade bei mir vor Ort? Und wenn man sich das mal anschaut, man kann sich das in der App tatsächlich anschauen, alle Rückmeldungen, die da einlaufen und das vergleicht mit der Vorhersage des Wetters.
Dann sieht man wo es genau passt, wo's vielleicht Abweichungen gab und so weiter. Das heißt, wir haben hier eine.
Wenn man so ein Schwarmintelligenz, die genutzt wird, um auch eine Rückmeldung in die Wettervorhersagen zu holen und ich glaube, das ist ein Bereich, der ähm der sehr interessant ist.
Und äh ich kann mir vorstellen, dass die Wetterdienste das äh durchaus auch auswerten und diese Rückmeldung sich einholen. Ob man jetzt als Amateur-Wettervorhersager oder Beobachter,
ähm Sachen Dinge entdeckt in in den Wettervorher, äh in dem Wetterphänomen, die es vorher noch nicht gab, das weiß ich nicht, das kann ich nicht sagen, dazu bin ich kein Fachmann, aber ich glaube, hier geht's in erster Linie tatsächlich um die um die Rückmeldung äh zu den Vorhersagen.
Underground, die haben, glaube ich, damit angefangen seiner Zeit äh mit der App, also diese Idee ist ja vor einigen Jahren so geboren worden, dass man quasi so das Wetter nicht unbedingt nur aus äh,
Vorhersagen macht, sondern eigentlich aus äh Berichterstattung einfach von den Leuten selber hier regnet's jetzt gerade.
Zumindest eben zusammenbringt. Schön zu sehen, wenn das dann auch irgendwann wieder in diese Modelle einfließen kann, weil das ist ja immer so auch das Ding, gerade bei so modernen Algorithmen wie Machine Learning, die ja sicherlich hier auch eine große Rolle spielen, weil
Irgendwann hat man auch einfach zu viel Daten. Also oder irgendwann ist es auch einfach zu komplex beziehungsweise es gibt so eine Vielzahl von Parametern, an denen man drehen kann, dass dann auch
irgendwann man einfach gar nicht mehr weiß, okay äh.
Ich kann hier gar nicht mehr so eine klare Logik aufbauen, dass wenn dies dann das und dann jenes, sondern das sind einfach alles ja chaotische Systeme, einfach äh die ganze Thermodynamik, was da alles irgendwie zusammenkommt, sind einfach chaotische Systeme, die natürlich zwangsläufig irgendein Ergebnis bringen, aber es lässt sich einfach nicht so ohne Weiteres
Vorhersagen. Man kommt vielleicht immer auf 99 Prozent, aber für dieses letzte äh Prozent, da geht dann immer schnell alles ausm Leim. Und ähm.
Ist ja so ein bisschen so dieser Ansatz, na egal, äh wir müssen gar nicht alles verstehen, was die Daten sagen. Wir haben einfach nur einen Ansatz, dass wir sagen, okay, das sind die Daten, das ist das Ergebnis, was bei diesen Sachen rausgekommen sind. Also können wir irgendwie einfach
durch das fortwährende Betrachten eben mit Deep Learning äh äh Methoden einfach diese Wahrheit aus diesen Daten rausmachen, ohne sie selber wirklich,
verstanden zu haben. Man kann einfach nur sagen, sehr wahrscheinlich, dass wenn es so ist, dass dann das passiert, weil es ist vorher ja auch schon mal gewesen.
Ja und ich denke, dass dass wir Menschen da auch ein bisschen an die Grenzen
unserer Auswertungs- und Interpretationsfähigkeit kommen. Wir haben nun mal ein sehr einfach strukturiertes ähm ja Wahrnehmungssystem und äh,
die die Anwendung von künstlicher Intelligenz und Maschinenlearning et cetera in dem Bereich der der Auswertung dieser Messdaten nimmt immer stärker zu. Also die großen Wetterdienste, ist egal, ob's jetzt der deutsche Wetterdienst ist, aber auch der der französische Meteoro France oder der britische,
Met Office, andere andere Wetterdienste,
wenden mehr und mehr oder versuchen mehr und mehr solche äh Algorithmen in der künstlichen Intelligenz und des Maschinen-Learning auch anzuwenden, um diese Vielzahl an Informationen auszuwerten.
Hat so als Dienstleister, also wie mit wie vielen Wetterdiensten wird hier so zusammengearbeitet so, Pi mal Daumen, also wenn man mal so die Großen heranzieht.
Also wie gesagt, äh die die ähm Wetterdienste an sich, das sind erstmal alle Wetterdienste unserer Mitgliedsländer, also die 30 nationalen Wetterdienste. Jedes Land hat ja nach wie vor. Wir haben ja noch keinen europäischen,
Wetterdienst an sich. Wir haben ein europäisches Zentrum für nomerische Wettervorhersage. Ähm das ist eine eine Bündelung,
europäischer Kompetenzen im Bereich der computergestützten Auswertung und computergestützten Vorhersage von Wetter, rein auf numerischer Basis. Auch hier hat Europa,
ähm wirklich die Nase vorn, kann man ganz klar sagen. Das übrigens tatsächlich äh auch äh erkennen die Amerikaner neidlos an, dass hier das europäische Wettervorhersagemodell eines der genausten der Welt ist,
Ähm und dieses Zentrum ist tatsächlich auf europäischer Ebene tätig.
Aber ansonsten haben wir in den Mitgliedsländern eben die nationalen Wetterdienste. Und wir haben ähm je nachdem wie das äh organisiert ist in den anderen Ländern, natürlich Kontakt zum russischen,
japanischen, zum Chinesischen, zum amerikanischen äh Wetterdienst. Wir haben insbesondere ganz viel Kontakt zu den afrikanischen Wetterdiensten.
Das verlieren wir ein bisschen aus dem Blick, aber auch hier gilt ja wieder, dass wir,
ähm über Frankreich, über Großbritannien, aber auch über andere Länder, sehr enge kulturelle Verbindungen und historische Verbindungen eben nach Afrika auch haben.
Dort wird gesagt, wir müssen eigentlich den afrikanischen Kontinent unterstützen,
in der Nutzung solcher Wetterdaten, denn wir kriegen sie ja automatisch mit aus dem Orbit von den Satelliten. Ja, die werden ja sozusagen frei Haus mitgeliefert. Da haben wir Afrika immer voll im Blick, fast noch besser als Europa.
Und insofern ist es unsere Aufgabe, den Wetterdiensten dort,
Methoden an die Hand zu geben, die Software, aber auch das Training der Meteorologen, damit die diese Daten nutzen können, damit die eben für ihre lokale Landwirtschaft, für das, für die Entwicklung des Mikroklimas.
Für die Entwicklung der Wüstenregion, aber auch des Regenwalds in Afrika für ähm Fischereidienste, um die Küsten um Afrika herum. Diese Daten nutzen können. Und da haben wir also sehr sehr engen Kontakt auch nach Afrika.
Wie gut ist denn die Wettervorhersage jetzt so geworden? Also ich weiß, das entsteht jetzt hier nicht so primär, aber das ist ja,
letztlich das Ziel und ähm damit ja auch,
Inhalt der permanenten Diskussion aller Gremien, der Optimierung, der Instrumente et cetera. Man man will's ja halt immer genauer äh wissen
und wenn du jetzt sagst, äh okay, das Modell in Europa, das ist äh führen kann, kriegt das so genau hin, dann ist das ja im Prinzip so dieser Versuch,
die Erde äh quasi, ich sage mal salopp so als Maschine zu verstehen im Wetterbereich und in irgendeiner Form möglichst nah rankommen äh an an das wo,
was man nie erreichen wird, ne? Das ist das ist ja immer so eine.
Ja, ja.
Ziel. Wie weit kommt man jetzt? Weil es ist ja schon,
einiges passiert. Ich meine, man schaut so auf sein Telefon und man sieht so, aha, okay, Wetter für die nächsten zehn Tage. Das ist schon, finde ich, eine, eine ziemliche Leistung, denn,
auch wenn jetzt die Regenwahrscheinlichkeit dann an einem Tag, wo es mal sechzig Prozent hieß, dann dazu geführt hat, dass es doch nicht geregnet hat. Meine bleiben ja immer noch vierzig Prozent
Ähm so ist das äh man kriegt schon ein relativ gutes Gefühl dafür, wie sich's vermutlich entwickeln kann. Wie weit kann man überhaupt in die Zukunft blicken, wo ist irgendwann Schluss und wie genau
vor allem wie bemisst man diese Genauigkeit?
Mhm. Ja, das waren ganz viele, ganz viele Einzelfragen.
Ist, wie gut kann man das Wetter vorher.
Genau, wir fangen mal, wir fangen mal oben an. Ähm erstmal ist es.
Ja wichtig, dass wie du vorhin schon gesagt hast, Wettersysteme, chaotische Systeme sind, ja, also man kann,
nur begrenzt für jeden Ort zu jedem Zeitpunkt des 1:1 vorhersagen. Da gibt's ganz viele Störgrößen. Man müsste eine einen enormen Rechenaufwand hineinstecken. Man müsste quasi,
Ganz kleine Zellen, ja von von ein paar Metern Durchmesser einzeln betrachten, um,
um jeden Einfluss da äh in Betracht ziehen zu können. Deswegen bleibt immer eine Restunggenauigkeit, aber ich find's wahnsinnig spannend zu sehen, wie sich das tatsächlich weiterentwickelt und wir haben da natürlich mal lange Zeit rein. Ja also man man guckt immer,
Man vergleicht die Vorhersage mit dem dann später tatsächlich eingetretenen Wetter. Ja, denn das tatsächlich eingetretene Wetter, das ist ja relativ leicht festzustellen. Das kann man einfach ausm Fenster gucken und sehen oder messen.
Und das vergleicht man mit der Vorhersage für den Tag und dann kriegt man prozentual die Abweichung oder die Genauigkeit der Vorhersage gegenüber dem tatsächlich eingetretenen Wetter dann heraus. Und wir hatten in den, sage ich mal, frühen achtziger Jahren.
Hatten wir so genau, Vorhersage-Genauigkeiten um die 80 Prozent für die nächsten drei Tage. So gemittelt.
Und da gab's auch noch große Unterschiede zwischen der Nord- und der Südhalbkugel, weil auf der Nordhalbkugel entwickeltere Länder sind mit höher entwickelten,
dichteren Messstationen, die dann auch noch genauere Bodenwerte hatten, weiterentwickelte Vorhersagesysteme et cetera.
Da gab's durchaus nochmal einen Unterschied von 15 Prozent in der Vorhersage, Genauigkeit zwischen Nord und Süd, Halbkugel der Erde. Und das hat sich dann mit der Einführung von mehr und mehr Satelliten immer weiter,
geschlossen diese Schere, sodass wir heutzutage fast kaum noch einen Unterschied in der Vorhersage Genauigkeit zwischen der Nord und der Südhalbkugel feststellen können, weil die Satelliten einfach global die Daten in gleicher Qualität liefern.
Und wir sind jetzt bei den drei Tage Vorhersagen äh auf einen Wert von ungefähr achtundneunzig Prozent.
Das kann man ähm ist wirklich erstaunlich, aber das kann man wirklich so sagen, dass ähm gemittelt in einer Region und das gilt natürlich nicht für den einzelnen Vorgarten. Ich kann mich jetzt nicht in den eigenen Vorgarten stellen und sagen, hier hat's aber nicht geregnet, also stimmt die Wettervorhersage nicht,
das gilt schon für eine regionale Region und ich sage mal typischerweise das Aartal ist eine Region, ja, wofür die man sehr gut vorhersagen konnte, was da passiert.
Also da wo wir jetzt gerade die Flutkatastrophe erlebt haben.
Da sind wir bei Genauigkeiten von ungefähr achtundneunzig Prozent und ich glaube, das ist schon mal ein ziemlich guter Wert. Wenn wir jetzt auf, sagen wir, fünf Tage gehen,
Das ist ja so ein Horizont, ja, Anfang der Woche. Guckt mal, wie plant man sein Wochenende. Und äh guckt fünf Tage äh im Voraus, dann sind wir immerhin noch bei Genauigkeiten von über neunzig Prozent.
Vorhersage Genauigkeit. Das finde ich ist auch schon mal ganz eine ganz gute Orientierungswert.
Ähm zehn Tage würde ich persönlich ja, kann man mal reingucken, aber sehe ich mehr so als Orientierungswert. Da sind wir heute bei einer Genauigkeit von ungefähr fünfzig Prozent.
Das ist nett, aber ähm ob ich da jetzt nun nun viel Geld drauf verwetten würde, weiß ich nicht. Von daher so drei bis fünf Tage,
Das ist etwas, was man wirklich sehr, sehr ernst nehmen kann und ich sage an der Stelle gerne noch mal auch ernst nehmen soll.
Ich befürchte und haben eben das Aartal kurz angesprochen. Ja, man ist so gewohnt, aus den sechziger, siebziger Jahren. Na ja, guckt mal ausm Fenster, ob's regnet oder nicht und dann weiß man schon, wie's Wetter wird. Das ist heute anders.
Heutzutage eine Wetterwarnung über die Systeme kommt, über die App.
Man hat aufm Telefon oder über das Radio oder über welche Quelle auch immer und da kommt eine Wetterwarnung,
sollte man die wirklich ernst nehmen, denn so genau sind die Vorhersagen,
auf jeden Fall, dass man das wirklich ernst nehmen kann, insbesondere für eine für eine Region. Und äh ich glaube, das müssen wir lernen. Das wäre tatsächlich,
zuverlässige Wettervorhersagen heutzutage haben, auf die wir uns verlassen können und die wir ernst nehmen sollen, insbesondere in dem Bereich der nächsten Brei, vier Tage.
Wie genau waren denn die Vorhersagen bei der Flutkatastrophe von äh im im Ahrtal.
Also es gab ja eine eine solche Warnung. Die war auch,
Ich habe sie jetzt nicht gelesen, aber so wie ich das wahrgenommen habe, war die relativ explizites wurde von starken Regenfällen, schweren Starkregen gesprochen und der Chance auf äh Überflutungen.
Wie genau war diese Ansage und hat man das Gefühl, dass sich das jemand äh durchgelesen hat.
Also äh das das Eis wird jetzt natürlich äh mikrometerdünn äh auf was auf das wir uns da bewegen. Deswegen glaube ich, diese Auswertung müssen wir wirklich den Kreisen überlassen, die da direkt involviert waren.
Wir können uns das ja nur von ganz, ganz weit weg angucken, also nicht nur, weil wir ein 36.000 Kilometer Höhe sind, sondern weil wir wirklich in diese in diese Anwendung solcher Vorhersagen äh gar nicht direkt involviert sind. Mein Eindruck,
ist nur, dass die die Vorhersage der Niederschlagsmenge,
der eigentlichen Wetterlage durchaus verfügbar war. Also die Kollegen vom Deutschen Wetterdienst haben da, glaube ich, eine ganz genaue und hervorragend und absolut zuverlässige Vorhersage geliefert.
Was vielleicht schwierig war einzuschätzen vor Ort war die die Interpretation, was bedeutet denn eine solche Durchschnittsregenmenge pro Quadratmeter?
Für meine geographische Besonderheit, wo ich in einem Flusstal sitze, wo sich solche Regenmengen dann natürlich sammeln, ja, dann dann ist natürlich eine Regenhöhe von ein paar Zentimetern erstmal schockiert mich nicht, aber wenn ich in einem Tal sitze und mir kommt eine Flut wähle.
Man kriegt sozusagen die Regenmenge von allen anderen auch mit dazu.
Dann wird's dann führt es natürlich zu solchen Effekten die man in dem Moment ähm äh vielleicht nicht nicht so eingeschätzt hat.
Aber das lag nicht an den Vorhersagen der Regenmengen, sondern das ist dann die die lokale Flutvorhersage, aber ich glaube auch dafür gibt es Modelle. Wir wissen ja,
das ist europaweit ein Flutvorhersage-Modell gibt, auch für Inlandgewässer und ich glaube, das ist insgesamt der Punkt, deswegen möchte ich das nochmal unterstreichen. Wir sind in einer Phase,
wir sind nicht mehr in den siebziger, achtziger Jahren, wo sowas aus Erfahrungswerten, aus händischen Betrachtungen, aus, ich sage mal, den Gesprächen mit den Altvorderen irgendwie aus Erfahrungswerten oder aus Bauernregeln abzuleiten ist.
Sind in Europa in der Lage, mit den Modellen und mit den äh Daten, die wir haben.
Sehr lokal, sehr genau und ernstzunehmende Vorhersagen zu machen und ich glaube, wir müssen alle miteinander lernen, dass wir in einer Phase sind, wo man solchen Vorhersagen durchaus Glauben schenken kann und auch sollte. Und dann sollte man sich nicht,
zurücklehnen und sagen, na ja, eine Meldung unter vielen, sondern auch muss in der Lage sein, zu erkennen, dass das jetzt wirklich eine ernstzunehmende Warnmeldung ist.
Dahin kommen, haben wir, glaube ich, schon sehr, sehr viel gewonnen.
Ein bisschen in die Zukunft jetzt haben wir ja im Prinzip alles beschrieben, was hier funktioniert,
der ganze Campus hier in äh Darmstadt arbeitet halt am Betrieb. All dieser Systeme, der Betrieb der Satelliten, Auswertung der Daten, ähm die ganze Kommunikation mit der Wissenschaft und der Technik,
um das alles am Laufen zu halten. Es gibt derzeit die Meteorosat-Gero-Synchronen, geostationären Satelliten. Es gibt äh die MetOp äh,
Missionen, die halt auf tausend Kilometer Höhe äh mit diesem Polaren äh Orbit die äh Erde beobachten und die Zusammenarbeit,
ähm Kopernikus beziehungsweise Zuarbeit zu Kopernikus. Es gibt dann, glaube ich, auch noch so einen kleinen Satelliten, der sich nur für Seewetter noch zuständig äh fühlt, diesen Jason.
Satelliten.
Das ist ein das ist ein ganz ähm besonders äh besonderer Satellit tatsächlich. Der ist ähm ähm das ist ein Programm, was in den neunziger Jahren schon angefangen hat.
Ähm aber was durch Nachfolgesatelliten immer weiter fortgesetzt wird und jetzt mittlerweile ist Eumetsat dafür zuständig für den Betrieb,
ähm nennt sich aus der Historie tatsächlich Jason. Ähm war ursprünglich mal ein amerikanisch-französisches Kooperationsprojekt,
und sollte äh dienen der Vermessung der Meereshöhe und zum Teil auch der Eisbedeckung.
Und es hat sich herausgestellt, was man gar nicht zu Anfang vielleicht in der Form absehen konnte,
dass die Beobachtung der der Entwicklung des Meeresspiegels eine eine enorme,
Relevanz hat, auch für die Veränderung des Klimas. Ja, heute sprechen wir ja ganz oft, wenn man vom vom Klimawandel sprechen, nicht nur von der Erwärmung, der Atmosphäre, sondern auch den Folgen, die das hat, auch auf die Polgebiete,
sekundär damit auch auf die Erhöhung des Meeresspiegels. Und der Nachweis, dass dich tatsächlich der Meeresspiegel in den letzten Jahrzehnten.
Um drei, vier Millimeter pro Jahr im Durchschnitt erhöht hat, der ist mit diesem Jason Satelliten gelungen. Ähm heute.
Der mit der letzten aktuellen fliegenden äh Familie der Satelliten ähm äh ist das jetzt Teil der Senti Nail Familie übrigens. Also die werden jetzt auch finanziert durch die Europäische Kommission. Das ist der Senti Nail sechs Satellit.
Den wir von hier äh betreiben hier von äh von Darmstadt aus. Ähm und ist nach wie vor ein europäisches amerikanisches Kooperationsprojekt.
Und äh diese dienen tatsächlich permanent der Vermessung des Meeresspiegels, auch der Wellenhöhen,
aus den Wellenhöhen kann man dann zum Beispiel die Windgeschwindigkeit lokal noch ableiten. Aber das sind dann sekundäre Größen, die daraus abgeleitet werden. In erster Linie vermisst man den Meeresspiegel und die Wellenhöhen dadurch.
Mhm. Gibt auch noch eine Isarmission zur Vermessung äh der Eisdeckel, der Kryosatt, der spielt da wahrscheinlich auch noch mit rein.
Was sind so die nächsten Missionen, die jetzt anstehen? Wie wird sich das Programm weiterentwickeln, jetzt wo die dritte Generation unterwegs ist? Ich habe so das Gefühl, da kommt noch mehr.
Ja ja, also wir haben tatsächlich in den nächsten fünf Jahren hier äh einiges auf dem Zettel. Wir haben insgesamt,
elf verschiedene Satelliten, die wir dann in verschiedenen äh Ausprägungen unterstützen, also angefangen von unseren eigenen Satelliten, die wir eben schon genannt haben, den den Meteosatz und den äh den MetOps. Das sind ja unsere ureigensten,
Wetter- und Klimasatelliten, die wir entwickeln lassen und dann auch starten und betreiben in vollem Umfange und wo wir auch für die Daten verantwortlich sind und alle Produkte.
Bis hin zu den Missionen, wo wir eine Teilrolle, eine unterstützende Rolle spielen. Da gibt's verschiedene Missionen, wo wir zum Beispiel dafür sorgen, dass die Daten,
möglichst schnell zu den Nutzern geraten, ja? Weil das ist eine unserer Spezialitäten hier in wir haben Systeme die sehr sehr schnell solche Messdaten von den Satelliten zu den Nutzern schaffen,
und äh da unterstützen wir anderer anderer Missionen äh mit unserem System das hinzubekommen.
Wir werden aber auch, das darf man äh ähm ja an der Stelle vielleicht mal erwähnen,
Wir werden äh für die Europäische Kommission zu einem der größten Betreiber des Sentinell Missionen, also die äh Senti Nate vier und fünf,
das sind einzelne Instrumente, die werden wir äh auf unseren Satelliten mitnehmen und dann auch betreiben,
Santinel 6 ist der eben wie erwähnte äh der Satellit, der die Meeresspiegelhöhe misst. Den betreiben wir auch,
Sentinell drei, das ist eine eher Erdbeobachtungsorientierte Mission, die aber auch äh Meeres äh Beobachtungen macht. Die betreiben wir gemeinsam mit der Esa. Da sind wir also jeweils fifty-fifty zuständig für verschiedene Produkte.
Äh in der Zukunft haben wir eine ganz ganz wichtige Mission, die noch dazukommt. Das ist die ähm Vermessung,
des menschgemachten Kohlendioxids in der Atmosphäre. Das ist ein bisschen kompliziert,
Kohlendioxid an sich ist ja ein normaler Bestandteil der Atmosphäre in einem sehr geringen Prozentsatz. Der entsteht ganz normal durch verschiedene Prozesse, Waldbrände.
Vulkanausbrüche, aber auch Zersetzungsprozesse et cetera. Also es gibt immer ein bisschen CO2 in der Atmosphäre.
Das wollen wir ja, das ist interessant, aber das macht ja nicht den Klimawandel.
Klimawandel wird verursacht durch den durch den Menschen hin zusätzlich eingebrachte CO2 durch die Verbrennung eben von äh Benzin Erdöl, Erdgas et cetera
und dieses menschgemachte CO2, das wird durch den äh nächsten Cent die Nailsatelliten äh vermessen,
und äh auch der ist jetzt gestartet in seiner Entwicklung, das heißt äh da sind Instrument und Satellit in der Entwicklung bei der Isar wieder, bei der europäischen Raumfahrtagentur und wir bereiten uns hier auf,
Die Auswertung der Daten vor, das heißt, wir haben die Software, die diese Daten dann auswertet, die entsprechenden,
Messwerte und und äh CO2-Werte extrahiert und verteilen dann diese Daten an die verschiedenen Institute und wir betreiben den Satelliten auch. Also wir hatten insgesamt tatsächlich hier,
ähm äh fünf Sentinell-Missionen dann betreiben. Das ist schon mal ein wichtiger, zukünftiger Schritt auch für.
Und ähm ja, ein ganz wichtiges Thema wird natürlich auch ähm die Frage sein, inwieweit,
zum Beispiel sogenannte also die mehr und mehr kommerziell ausgerichteten Raumfahrt äh Unternehmen,
die weg äh gehen, entweder weggehen von staatlichen Raumfahrtaufträgen, sondern sich eigene kommerzielle Nischen suchen,
oder Start-ups. Ja, junge Unternehmen, die die ähm verfügbaren Daten nutzen, um daraus eben Produkte zu entwickeln und Auswertungen zu machen, wie wir das vorhin schon mal angesprochen haben, auf der Basis von von Daten in den Clouds.
Äh inwieweit wir die mit einbeziehen in unseren unseren Netzwerk, also auch hier wird sicherlich eine Rolle spielen,
bei in dem Netzwerk äh all dieser dieser Unternehmen, die dann kommerziell basierte Daten liefern, die aber auch in äh in dem Netzwerk verfügbar sein sollen, ne, von von Forschungsinstituten und kommerziellen Anwendern.
Da wird sicherlich auch eine eine Kernkompetenz haben, eben zur Verfügung stellen dieser Daten.
Es gibt noch so eine Windmission von der Esa Eolus. Da gibt's auch eine Kooperation mit.
Ja genau. Ist tatsächlich ein Satellit, der fliegt schon. Das ist ein ein äh ja wie soll man sagen, ein Demonstrator, der Isar.
Ähm da sollte ich vielleicht ein bisschen ausholen. Das ist nämlich wirklich sehr, sehr interessant,
Und zwar hat man sich gefragt, ähm wie schaffen wir es, vom Weltraum aus, von einem Satelliten direkt die Windgeschwindigkeit in der Atmosphäre zu vermessen?
Bisher guckt man sich zum Beispiel die Höhe der Wellen auf dem Meer an und die Richtung, in der diese Wellen sich fortbewegen,
leitet daraus ab, wie denn wohl der Wind sein muss, der da drüber hinweg weht, um solche Wellen zu generieren und versucht daraus eben Windrichtung und Windstärke abzuleiten über den Meeren, als Beispiel oder man schaut sich Wolken an und schaut, wie schnell,
die Driften und leitet daraus ab, wie denn wohl der Wind in der Höhe dieser Wolken sein muss, damit die Wolken in dieser Geschwindigkeit driften und so weiter, sind aber sekundäre Ableitungen der Windgeschwindigkeit,
Man hat sich gesagt, es muss doch möglich sein, die Windgeschwindigkeit direkt zu messen,
Zum Beispiel, indem man mit einem Laser, einem sehr starken Laser in die Atmosphäre leuchten.
Und dann durch Staubkörner oder Wassertröpfchen reflektiertes Laserlicht? Wieder auffangen.
Und dann quasi den Doppler-Effekt messen, also die Verschiebung der Wellenlänge des Lasers durch die Bewegung dieser Tröpfchen oder der Staubkarne.
Aber den Abstand der der der Staubkörnchen die man.
Die Geschwindigkeit. Durch den Dopple-Effekt messen wir die Geschwindigkeit. Denn dieses Tröpfchen, die dieser Tröpfchen oder diese Staubkorn in der Atmosphäre in dem Moment hat.
Man kann sogar soweit gehen, dass man einzelne Moleküle in der Atmosphäre.
Ach so, also man schießt so quasi so quer in die Atmosphäre rein, nicht so direkt von oben nach unten, sondern quasi schräg. Ah ja. Okay.
Schickt da rein und misst dann das reflektierte Licht und je nachdem, ob das eine längere Wellenlänge bekommen hat, das reflektierte oder eine kürzere, weiß man, ob das Teilchen auf einen zugeflogen ist oder von einem weggeflogen ist.
In der Blickrichtung des Lasers kann man dann die Windgeschwindigkeit sozusagen direkt messen.
Mhm. Verstehe.
Dieser dieser Prototyp ist von der Isar mit mit äh einem enormen technologischen Herausforderungen tatsächlich,
ähm entwickelt worden. Der wurde 2018 gestartet,
äh ist jetzt immer noch in Betrieb, hat also seine Erwartung auch voll erfüllt, hat wirklich hervorragende Daten geliefert im Höhenprofil, ja, also nicht nur am Boden, wie man das zum Beispiel bei diesen Meereswellen rauskriegen könnte, da ist ja dann nur der Wind am an der.
Bei den Wolken, wo es in einer bestimmten Höhe ist, sondern dieser Laser kann das gesamte Profil über die Höhe der Atmosphäre vermessen, hat dort herausragende Messwerte erreicht und da haben wir gesagt, dieser Demonstrator hat so gut funktioniert,
dass es interessant wäre, so was tatsächlich auch operativ zu haben, also ein Satellit, der äh so was kontinuierlich dann misst und in die Wettermodelle einspeisen kann und daher,
jetzt eine Überlegung gemeinsam mit der Isar, ein Nachfolgesatelliten zu entwickeln, der dann also operativ tatsächlich fähig äh ist, über fünf, sechs Jahre Lebensdauer,
Solche Daten zu liefern und dann gibt's danach wieder Nachfolgesatelliten, sodass du es also Bestandteil der Satellitenfamilie wird.
Auch im Rahmen von ist das dann auch wieder irgendein Sentinel oder weiß man.
Nehmt dadurch, dass das wirklich tatsächlich eine reine Wetteranwendung ist oder eine atmosphärische Anwendung,
ist es, ähm wie ich vorhin sagte, ja wir sind ja komplementär sozusagen mit dem Kopernikus-Programm, ist das also hier im Satellit der, wenn er denn so kommt und so beschlossen wird, das muss natürlich durch die Mitgliedsstaaten erstmal noch so beschlossen werden, das ist noch nicht der Fall,
Aber wenn es kommt, dann wird es tatsächlich ein Satellit.
Okay und würde also hier noch die Familie noch um was Lustiges ergänzen.
Lustig und vor allen Dingen auch toll und gut.
Naja, das meine ich damit auch.
So toll ist, sondern weil die Daten gezeigt haben, also in den verschiedenen Wettermodellen, äh in die diese Daten eingespeist wurden, haben die also wirklich zu einer signifikanten Verbesserung der Vorhersage-Genauigkeit geführt.
Kann ich mir vorstellen. Ich meine, wie hoch ist die Auflösung, also äh der der unterschiedlichen Höhen, die man damit erreichen kann. Im Prinzip beliebig, also so im Meter Abstand oder zehn, hundert, weiß man noch nicht genau.
Also man muss immer abwägen zwischen der Datenmenge.
Und was ist sinnvoll, ja.
Man bekommt und und was die Modelle auch verarbeiten können, ne. Wir haben ja äh so ein Modell, so ein Wettermodell funktioniert ja, indem man die Atmosphäre quasi in kleine Würfel zerschneidet.
In der Höhe, aber auch in der Fläche,
und jedem jedem Würfel Messwerte zuordnet. Jeder Würfel hat eine Temperatur, jeder Würfel hat eine Luftfeuchtigkeit, ein Druck et cetera und dann verrechnet der Computer die Entwicklung und die gegenseitige Beeinflussung dieser Würfe.
Was ist da die klassische Kantenlänge, Kilometer?
Kilometer so ungefähr, ja.
Mhm. Ja.
Grob mal gesagt, ne? Also die größeren Wetterdienste, die sich auch die größeren Computer leisten können. Wie gesagt, der deutsche Wetterdienst ist hier wirklich vorne mit dran, auch weltweit, aber auch Meteoro France und und Met Office et cetera.
Aber auch die Amerikaner sind hier ganz vorne dran, die leisten sich größere Computersysteme, die können mehr Rechenaufwand verarbeiten, die haben dann auch kleinere Kantenlängen der Würfel, ja, weil sie's halt verarbeiten können,
ähm und die sind so im Kilometerbereich. Und wenn man, ich bekomme noch mal zurück auf diese App vom Deutschen Wetterdienst, da kann man tatsächlich sich diese numerischen Wettervorhersagen anschauen und die sind im Kantenbereich von einem Kilometer 1,2 Kilometer.
So und äh dementsprechend wird auch dieser Höhenauflösung, dieses Satelliten, dieses Wind,
Messungsateliten wird in dem Bereich liegen, dass man diese Wettermodelle optimal füllen kann. Ja, so eine höhere Auflösung bringt nix, weil das verarbeitet, das wird dann wieder verschmiert in einem Würfel. Das würde nix bringen. Eine gröbere Auflösung,
bringt unter Umständen trotzdem noch was,
aber wenn man zu grob wird, dann geht der Effekt wieder verloren. Also man versucht da möglichst dicht dran zu sein an einer sinnvollen Verarbeitbarkeit der Daten.
Sonnensynchronen Obit unterwegs ist, würde man aber immer quasi die ganze Welt abdecken, äh so im 24stunden-Modus. Ist einfach schon ein bisschen schade, wenn man so schön den Wind messen kann, wenn man das an jeder Stelle immer nur alle 24 Stunden,
macht. Würde man dann nicht gleich auch mit mehreren Satelliten parallel arbeiten wollen.
Oder stelle ich mir das jetzt schon zu wild vor? Man ist schon ganz froh, wenn man überhaupt alle 24 Stunden mal ein Update kriegt.
Also wenn sie mich heute Nacht nochmal fragen, kann ich ihnen nochmal aus meinen wildesten Träumen bisschen was erzählen und da kommen natürlich ganz, ganz viele Satelliten vor.
Ich bin interessiert.
Aber wenn ich tagsüber äh abwägen muss zwischen den den Kosten, die solche Satellitensysteme ja auch immer haben.
Und dem Effekt, den sie bringen können, wäre es mir.
Fast wichtiger, dass wir einen Satelliten bekommen, der kontinuierlich über die nächsten Jahre, ja, also nicht nur einen, der mal fünf Jahre funktioniert und dann wieder quasi ausfällt und dann haben wir wieder ein paar Jahre nix, sondern dass wir ein System etablieren, in dem kontinuierlich,
immer diese Satellitendaten zur Verfügung stehen. Ähm zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt über einem gegebenen Punkt der Erde,
das ist für mich viel wichtiger diese Kontinuität der Messdaten hinzubekommen als jetzt noch mehrere Satelliten parallel zu fliegen.
Und daher wäre ich schon sehr, sehr froh, wenn wir, wenn wir einen Satelliten in Orbit operativ in Betrieb nehmen könnten.
Verstehen, aber ich bin ja von solchen Zwecken befreit und überlege mir so, wenn man halt immer äh zur selben Tageszeit äh am selben an einem Ort ist, dann verpasst man ja sozusagen auch.
Die Nacht und man verpasst irgendwie den Morgen und den Abend und das ist ja grade bei Wind so eine Sache.
Aber mit dem Verpassen ist das so eine Sache. Wir wir müssen hier noch mal einen Schritt zurückgehen, dass nicht nur die der unmittelbare Messwert eine Aussagekraft hat, sondern.
Messwert im Konzert aller Messwerte. Das heißt, wenn wir einen Messwert an einer Stelle bekommen, können wir durch Extrapulation über dieses gesamte.
Ja dieses dieses Netzwerk an Würfeln hinweg sozusagen extra polieren in die anderen Würfel hinein.
Messwert nicht haben, haben wir keine Idee, was da passiert. Aber wenn wir einen Messwert haben, haben wir eine Stützstelle sozusagen, einen Fixpunkt.
Mhm. Dann kann man den Rest reinrechnen.
Ableiten, genau und das ist ein ganz wichtiges äh ganz wichtiger Effekt, den wir den wir hier sehen und dadurch stabilisiert ein solcher Messwert,
die anderen Ableitungen, die anderen Messwerte noch mal zusätzlich und das gibt den positiven Effekt. Also ist gar nicht so schlimm, dass wir nicht für jeden Würfel, zu jeder Zeit, zu jedem Zeitpunkt einen bestimmten Messwert haben, sondern,
Dass wir einfach wissen, an welche zu welchem Zeitpunkt für welchen Würfel wir eine Stützstelle bekommen.
Verstehe. Ich unterstütze das. Ähm und es macht auch alles äh sehr viel Sinn. Ich äh würde sagen, an der Stelle können wir,
das Gespräch dann auch äh zu Ende bringen. Das war sehr äh ein sehr interessanter Ausblick äh äh auf all das, was äh bei Omezard äh gemacht.
Großen Konzert aller äh Organisationen. Ich sage vielen Dank.
Ja und das äh war's für heute bei Raumzeit. Das war die 97. Ausgabe. Ihr wisst, bald geht's wieder weiter und bis dahin sage ich.